l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée
confortant le respect des principes de
la république
nous allons aborder maintenant la
discussion générale et je vais donner la
parole à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur gérald darmanin
s'il veut bien venir à la tribune
extra monsieur le président du sénat
monsieur présent de la commission des
lois
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le musée des questions
nationales de ce garde des sceaux madame
la ministre déléguée la république est
attaquée depuis de nombreuses années par
d'étonnants ceux du séparatisme cela
radicalisation qui mène au terrorisme
trois gouvernements successifs et
singulièrement des gouvernements qui ont
agi à la suite d'attentats nos triés sur
le territoire national ont pris des
dispositions très importante
législatives réglementaires en moyens
pour lutter contre la radicalisation
pour lutter contre le terrorisme mais
jusqu'à présent nous avons refusé
collectivement de voir en tout cas la
loi ne l'avait pas prévu qu entre
l'islam politique
le communautarisme la séparation avec
les valeurs et les buts de la république
et la radicalisation et le terrorisme il
y avait une différence de nature alors
que nous constatons et l'odieux
assassinat de semelle bâti est là pour
témoigner
ce n'était qu'une différence de degré
dans son discours des mureaux le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion d'évoquer l'ensemble de
l'arsenal législatif réglementaire de
moyens que le gouvernement de la
république de mettre en place sous son
autorité pour lutter contre ces
séparatisme
si je devais les caricatures et je
dirais qu'ils sont de deux ordres
parfois complémentaires souvent
différent d'une part à l'évidence un
séparatisme et le premier d'entre eux le
séparatisme islamistes visent à imposer
des règles qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
religion mais tout à voir avec
l'idéologie et s'étend dans le champ des
services publics du chant administrative
associatif sur internet au sein d'
éducation qu'il s'agisse d'éducation des
parents une éducation de l'école dans la
vie de nos concitoyens
une vie qui les touchent évidemment
parfois même si ça devient de moins en
moins vrai dans leurs lieux cultuels et
puis un show qui n'a souvent pas grand
chose à voir avec ce séparatisme
islamistes mais qui sont les ingérences
étrangères
il nous faut les distinguer les
combattre et rappelé que depuis philippe
le bel la volonté de l'état français
sous les rois sous l' empire puis sous
la république et de considérer que la
liberté religieuse les affaires
religieuses
c'est une affaire qui relève de l'état
du pouvoir public et non d'état
étrangers ce travail nous n'avons imposé
par quasiment six siècles de travail de
sécularisation d'abord aux catholiques
et aux protestants puis de nouveau aux
juifs et aux catholiques et depuis de
nombreuses années plusieurs
gouvernements différents essaye c'est
bien normal que cela prenne du temps de
l'imposer nous espérons définitivement
au culte musulman lutte contre le
séparatisme islamistes dans tous les
champs insidieux de la société lutte
pour la sécularisation et si j'ose dire
une forme de all à donner à ceux qui
veulent utiliser la religion comme
contrôle de leur diaspora comme soft
power sur le territoire national voilà
le but d'un texte important déposé
monsieur le président du sénat 115 ans
jour pour jour après l'assemblée
nationale qui a réussi avec aristide
briand a créé ce compromis parfois à
discuter parfois conflictuelles avec les
grandes forces politiques qui ensuite
philosophique du pays et je n'oublie pas
que le sénat et permettez moi ces
tribunes monsieur le président de saluer
le sénateur gustave dron sénateur maire
de tourcoing qui fut le rapporteur pour
une partie du texte de loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état et qui a porté
de façon définitive
le compromis qui allait nous permettre
sans doute de vivre encore sous l'empiré
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
laïcité
il faut d'abord la définir pour pouvoir
l'imposer et la combinaison de trois
choses la pluralité religieuse et le
gouvernement à la demande du président
de la république réaffirmera la
pluralité religieuse
le fait que l'état la république ne
reconnaît aucun culte et ainsi doit
garantir la liberté de culte dans des
lieux bien sûr mais dans l'expression
religieuse comme l'article 10 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen le prévoit nul ne peut être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses le même soulignant sans
doute déjà le certaine inquiétude
d'aspirer l'opinion religieuse devant
les difficultés et parfois avoir le les
crispations que les religions entre ceux
qui croient à ceux qui ne croient pas
peuvent avoir dans le champ public
mais cette pluralité religieuse fait
partie intégrante de la laïcité
française
la deuxième composante de la laïcité est
à l'évidence la possibilité pour l'état
pour les pouvoirs publics d'imposer la
neutralité de son action la neutralité
de ces agents politiques et religieuses
neutralité que nous renforçons
considérablement dans les premiers
articles de ce texte de loi et notamment
dans l'article 1er qui vise à imposer
les principes les règles de la
neutralité à tous les services publics
ceux de l'état doivent évidemment en
tirer des conséquences
mais aussi ceux des collectivités
locales puisque nous avons tous
collectivement à mener vers un champ de
délégation de service public ou des
agents de droit privé concours et aux
services publics concours au service
public sans voir s'imposer les principes
de neutralité des agents du service
public
cette neutralité de l'état des pouvoirs
publics et de tous ses appendices des
offices hlm pôle emploi
cpm la caf et tout ce qui concourt aux
services publics doivent évidemment se
voir imposer ce qui dans les difficultés
parfois de la jurisprudence et dans la
mauvaise interprétation de certains
ces textes ont vu fleurir il faut bien
l'avouer parfois d'anaystes et parfois
de la compromission avec ceux qui
voulait bousculer les valeurs de la
république
nous pensons évidemment aux transports
en commun mais pas simplement tout ce
qui fait la une bien sûr de du quotidien
de nos concitoyens
le troisième point que je voudrais
évoquer évidemment et la question de
l'ordre public est jeune et monsieur le
président bien conscience que devant la
chambre qui représente des collectivités
locales très attentif aux libertés
publiques
nous devons toucher les grandes lois les
grands principes de notre état de droit
la liberté d'association la liberté
d'expression la liberté de culte qu'avec
une main tremblante mais quand même
assuré afin de garder l'ordre public et
c'est cet équilibre que nous devons
trouver ensemble
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
après un travail riche à l'assemblée
nationale et c'est dans cet esprit de
compromis républicain mais de fermeté
républicaine que le gouvernement vient
de vente
j'aurai l'occasion de porter devant vous
le début et la fin de ce texte qui
touchent évidemment à la question des
services publics qui touche à l'action
des élus locaux je pense au référé
liberté en lien direct avec ce que a
proposé le conseil d'état et qui touche
aux dispositions cultuelle très
importante riche et qui font naître des
débats notamment j'imagine sont les
immeubles de rapport ou sur les
dispositions pour forcer l'intégralité
des lieux de culte à passer sous
l'emprise de la loi de 1905 et de ne pas
rester en 1901 pour que nos compatriotes
musulmans fassent comme les protestants
comme les juifs avant te migration vers
la loi 1905 qui assez compromis ses
avantages mais aussi ses inconvénients
le garde des sceaux aura l'occasion de
défendre plusieurs dispositions très
importante celle en propre qui touchent
évidemment au délit pénal qu'il a bien
voulu proposer qui protégeront et
j'imagine qu'ils en détaillera le
service public mais aussi la haine en
ligne avec le secrétaire d'état au
numérique mais éducation nationale
évoquera la question évidemment
éducative et je veux avec lui souligné
le fait que ces dispositions sont
extrêmement importante bien sûr sur
l'instruction en famille mais aussi dans
les écoles hors contrat puisque
à l'instar de ce que nous faisons depuis
plusieurs mois désormais avec une grande
efficacité
nous rendons évidemment responsables
ceux qui utilisent les enfants pour
propager une idéologie on aura
l'occasion d'en répéter sans doute des
exemples très concrets et malheureux
dans le débat parlementaire et la
ministre déléguée aura l'occasion sur
les questions très essentiel de la vie
associative mais aussi de ceux qui
touchent à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
l'importance des dispositions je pense
aux contrats d'engagement républicain
que nous devons tous avoir dans la
défense de la république
nous avons bien conscience mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'il s'agit
d'un texte difficile difficile parce que
évidemment il ya de la passion
lorsque le législateur touche à l'intimé
aux convictions à la religion au fait de
croire ou de ne pas croire ce qu'a
souhaité le gouvernement c'est un texte
de fermeté qui n'est pas un texte qui
est là pour rajouter des pouvoirs de
police judiciaire dans le renseignement
la lutte contre le terrorisme
nous pensons que l'arsenal est déjà
suffisant il peut y avoir des
améliorations on aura l'occasion d'en
parler devant le sénat sans doute au
mois de juillet soit loi dit on de
renseignement la loi dit de sylt et
c'est ainsi que devant cette position le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité entrer
dans des dispositions qui concernait la
radicalisation qui mène directement au
terrorisme
le gouvernement n'a pas souhaité j'en
remercie la commission et les
rapporteurs d'avoir suivi son souhait de
ne pas mettre de dispositions qui
concernent le droit du travail dans le
privé
ces dispositions existent elles aident
notamment avec la discussion syndicale
aux chefs d'entreprises de prendre des
décisions son règlement intérieur
elles nous paraissent après consultation
suffisante
le gouvernement n'a pas souhaité non
plus légiférer sur les vêtements
religieux c'est un débat important qui
n'est pas médiocre
je peux comprendre les convictions des
uns et des autres mais il nous a semblé
plus efficace pour la république
après des années et des années de
polémique sur ce sujet de pouvoir rester
sur la conformité à la définition de la
laïcité c'est à dire que les expressions
religieuses
même si elles peuvent nous gêner même si
elle peut nous choquer sont conformes à
l'idée
que l'espace public est un lieu
d'expression et qui n'est pas un lieu de
réglementation des expressions
religieuses
j'imagine que le sénat aura l'occasion
d'en débattre comme longuement que
l'annoncé pendant l'assemblée nationale
enfin j'en terminerai par là je voudrais
dire ici aux associations cultuelles
occultes que nous respectons
profondément qui aujourd'hui se pose
sans doute de légitimes questions comme
à chaque fois que l'on vienne a évoqué
les dispositions qui les concernent que
nous seront sensibles aux arguments qui
ont été évoqués mais nous ne le
lâcherons pas sur ce qui nous paraît
essentiel
bien sûr aujourd'hui tout le monde nous
rappelle la loi de 1905 à commencer par
les associations cultuelles
nous saluons évidemment cet attachement
quasi unanime de la république à la loi
1905 il ne nous a pas semblé qu'en 1905
tous les cultes été très favorable à la
loi portée par aristide briand depuis un
équilibre a été trouvé en 1906 de
parlement s'est réuni quelques semaines
après seulement l'adoption de la loi
pour pouvoir légiférer afin de créer la
loi de 1907 et 7 connaît qu après la
première guerre mondiale voûte église
catholique refusé d'appliquer la loi
1905 qu'un compromis a été trouvé
il faut aussi dire que les accords
internationaux les échanges de lettres
entre leurs grands la république et le
nonce apostolique ne remet évidemment
pas en cause l'action de 1905 et
l'action de ce texte
en aucun cas ici l' équilibre qui a été
trouvé l'église catholique n'est remis
en cause mais nous voulons signifier ici
qu'on ne peut pas faire de reçus fiscaux
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
sans contrôle des comptes
on ne peut pas avoir du financement
étranger sur le sol de la république
santé république les connaissent on ne
peut pas permettre à la république de ne
pas s'opposer à ces financements
étrangers
on ne peut pas laisser parfois des
collectivités locales comme on l'a vu
récemment
même en respectant le droit
concordataire a accepté de financer des
ennemis de la république sur le sol de
la république et on ne peut pas
continuer à accepter qu'il y ait des
lieux séparatistes en territoire de la
république
on sent que le ministre de l'intérieur
depuis intervenir parce que mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs souvent vous
m'interpeller pour dire il ya tel ou tel
endroit que tout le monde considère
comme radicaliser dont l une des
journaux qui font la une des questions
d'actualité vous avez bien raison
aujourd'hui la loi dollar
public empêche mi hauteur de les fermer
sauf pour cause d'urbanisme mais un jour
viendra où les islamistes seront lire le
code de l'urbanisme
alors dans ces conditions mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires
il faut savoir écouter ce qui manque
dans la république et des gens qui à la
tête de structures cultuelle qui annonce
que les juifs sont des mécréants qui
annonce que les chrétiens sont à tuer
qui annonce que les femmes ne sont pas
légales des hommes qui annonce qu'on se
transforme en port quand on écoute de la
musique
alors il faut que la loi puisse tout en
respectant la liberté de culte
permettent à la fonction administrative
d'intervenir et de rendre peu de liberté
aux ennemis de la république je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant à madame la
ministre en charge de la citoyenneté
madame marlène schiappa
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs mais sur les ministres nous
avons présenté ce texte avec le ministre
de l'intérieur le 9 décembre 2020 115
ans après l'adoption de la loi de 1905
et ce texte est le fruit de larges
consultations avec la société civile les
partis politiques les représentants des
cultes les intellectuels les
associations philosophique
il a été examiné par l'assemblée
nationale qui a apporté de nombreuses
améliorations après plus de 80 heures de
débats en hémicycle et presque deux
mille sept cents amendements
nous avons eu depuis des échanges francs
avec mesdames et rapporteur dont je
voudrais ici saluer le travail et
l'engagement et nous nous présentons
aujourd'hui avec la même disposition
d'esprit et un objectif clair défendre
nos valeurs et la promesse républicaine
de la laïcité promesses de liberté
d'émancipation de progrès donné à la
république les moyens de lutter plus
efficacement contre ce que le président
de la république appelle le terreau du
terrorisme
nous rappelons ainsi la souveraineté
absolue des principes de la république
sous tout autre système
cela passe bien sûr par la neutralité
des services publics et par un meilleur
accompagnement des activités
associatives pour empêcher que n'y
prospère des discours et des pratiques
contraires aux valeurs de la république
notre mot d'ordre est clair pas un euro
d'argent public pour les ennemis de la
république et en ce sens comme l'a voulu
le président la république nous
proposons la création d'un contrat
d'engagement républicain évoquée par le
ministre de l'intérieur à l'instant
le principe en est claire les
associations qui souhaitent recevoir une
subvention publique s'engageront par ce
texte à respecter les valeurs de la
république et en cas de non respect
la subvention pourra être reprise ce
contrat d'engagement républicain élaboré
avec les élus et avec les associations
c'est un contrat de confiance avec le
monde associatif puisque l'immense
majorité des associations participent de
l'affreux républicaine mais une minorité
véhicule des valeurs contraires aux
principes sur lesquels repose la
république
grâce à ce contrat d'engagement
républicain l'état mais aussi les
collectivités auront à leurs mains un
outil juridique clair le respect des
principes de la république
il implique bien sûr celui de droits des
personnes et notamment de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
les idéologies séparatistes elle
s'attaque en premier lieu aux femmes
en voulant décider à leur place ce
qu'elles ont le droit de faire ou non
ces idéologies elle ne supporte pas leur
liberté qui préfigure celle de la
société dans tout son ensemble mais nous
pensons que toutes les femmes qui vivent
en france doivent être respectés dans
leur intégrité
elles doivent toutes être protégés dans
leur dignité dans leur liberté
je crois que le féminisme c'est de ne
pas accepter pour les autres femmes ce
que l'on ne tolérerait jamais pour nous
mêmes pour nos soeurs pour nos filles et
donc nous l'affirmons les pratiques
coutumières n'ont pas leur place en
france
mariages forcés polygamie discrimination
des filles face à l'héritage certificat
de virginité
ce texte permettra de renforcer encore
l'arsenal existant et de combler
certains vides juridiques
il ya des années de cela la france a eu
le courage de dire non à l'excision en
prenant une loi forte en montrant la
voie de nombreux pays du monde et en
portant ce travail de conviction via la
diplomatie féministe nous devons
aujourd'hui poursuivre ce combat ait osé
affirmer que la république ne tolère
aucune atteinte à la dignité humaine
qu'aucune atteinte à la dignité des
femmes net excusable au motif de la
coutume ou de la pratique c'est ce que
nous vous proposons avec le chapitre que
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité nommer
respect des droits des personnes et
égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans ce chapitre nous veillerons à
l'égalité traitement entre héritiers
afin que les filles ne puisse pas être
déshérités et je voudrais remercier le
garde des sceaux pour son engagement
personnel sur cette mesure nous
instaurerons également une réserve
générale de polygamie pour la délivrance
et le renouvellement des titres de
séjour
nous affirmerons que les hommes de
nationalité étrangère qui sont coupables
de faits de polygamie n'ont rien à faire
sur le sol français
nous voulons également interdire aux
professionnels de santé d'établir des
certificats de virginité les
professionnels qui en délivreront seront
passibles de poursuites et je vais être
très clair ce n'est pas en produisant
des certificat de virginité même des
certificats dits de complaisance que
nous améliorons la condition des jeunes
femmes qui sont victimes de pressions
séparatistes et ce n'est pas en france
en faisant cela que nous les protégerons
la commission des lois a d'ailleurs
souhaité apporté plusieurs modifications
aux tests dans lé prolongement des
débats de l'assemblée nationale pour
poursuivre légalement les personnes qui
incite ou contraignent à cette pratique
je crois que ces modifications vont dans
le bon sens
nous renforçons aussi la lutte contre
les mariages forcés après notamment
consultation de l'association des maires
de france
en rendant obligatoire la saisine du
procureur de la république par
l'officier d'état civil
dès lors qu'il ya un doute sérieux sur
le consentement de l'un des deux époux
toutes ces dispositions elles
s'accompagneront bien sûr de politique
publique forte pour les concrétiser
nous y travaillons déjà enfin le
ministre de l'intérieur et moi même
avons déposé à l'assemblée nationale des
amendements pour mieux renforcer la
laïcité dans le service public
la commission des lois de votre
assemblée a souhaité les maintenir dans
le texte que vous examinez je vous en
remercie car je crois que la laïcité est
le ciment de la citoyenneté le ciment de
la république et doit être au coeur du
service public mais d'amener sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs la loi que nous
portons je crois que c'est une loi de
liberté raisonnable équitable qui
respecte la liberté de culte et qui
protège la liberté de conscience c'est
une loi je l'espère qui fera honneur à
votre assemblée républicaine je vous
remercie pour votre attention
mais si madame la ministre la parole est
maintenant à monsieur le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
eric dupond moretti
la parole monsieur le président ce
président de la commission des doigts le
président de la commission de la culture
mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
messieurs les ministres
je suis heureux d'être cet après midi
aux côtés des sionistes de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin de madame schiappa de
monsieur jean michel blanquer pour la
discussion générale devant le sénat de
ce projet de lois confortant les
principes de la république
ce texte qui est un texte de liberté
porte une ambition défendre et protéger
notre république contre le fléau du
séparatisme notamment islamistes
cette ambition pour conforter le respect
des principes républicains s'inscrit
dans une approche globale portée par
chacun de nos ministères garantir
d'abord leur transmission par
l'enseignement à l'école prévenir
ensuite les infractions qui serait faite
à ses principes et enfin donner les
moyens juridiques d'une réponse pénale
rapide 6 thématiques adaptées à ces
actes qui s'appelait principes que nous
défendons tous et qui fondent la
république française
ce résultat ne pourra être atteint sans
une mobilisation totale de la justice de
notre pays et c'est pourquoi je porte au
nom de la chancellerie plusieurs
dispositions qui ont d'ailleurs été
maintenus ou enrichies par votre
commission
ainsi l'article 3 du projet de loi
élargit le dispositif collectif au
fichier des auteurs d'infractions
terroriste le fige est en y intégrant
désormais les infractions d'apologie et
de provocation au terrorisme il est
essentiel pour renforcer la lutte contre
le terrorisme que toutes personnes
postulant à un emploi ou effectivement
ou effectuant une demande d'habilitation
fasse l'objet d'un contrôle afin de
vérifier qu'elle n'a pas été condamné
mise en examen pour des infractions en
lien direct ou indirect avec des
activités terroristes par l'article 4
nous souhaitons renforcer la protection
que notre pays doit aux personnes qui
exercent des missions de service public
face à ceux qui par des comportements
violents ou menaçant remettent gravement
en cause notre capacité à vivre
sereinement ensemble il est urgent que
nos agents publics en première ligne
face à ces dérives séparatiste
sache que l'etat sera toujours à leurs
côtés et que la loi les protégera
désormais plus complètement parce que le
séparatisme use de tous les moyens pour
s'étendre ce projet de loi répond
également à une menace nouvelle est
pourtant déjà bien installés qui
consiste à détourner l' usage des
réseaux sociaux pour les transformer en
vecteur de diffusion de la haine la plus
féroce et la plus décomplexée c'est ce
que nous faisons avec l'article 18 de ce
projet de loi qui crée un délit de mise
en danger de la vie d'une personne par
diffusion d'informations personnelles
permettant son identification
l'effroyable assassinat terroriste qui a
coûté la vie au professeur samuel pâtit
nous l'a montré il nous faut enrichir
significativement notre arsenal
législatif pour lutter efficacement
contre cette haine pour sanctionner
efficacement la volonté de nuire à
autrui ce texte réprimera cette mise en
danger même si elle n'est pas suivie
d'effet
en revanche cette diffusion
d'informations personnelles sur internet
ne sera puni que si l'on démontre
l'intention manifeste de l'auteur de
porter gravement atteinte à la personne
visée ensuite puisque l'expression
dématérialisée et le temps de lui média
te tais il était absolument nécessaire
d'aligner le temps de la réponse jeudi
hier au rythme des infractions commises
c'est le sens de l'article 20 ne
permettra d'ouvrir le champ de la
comparution immédiate aux auteurs des
propos appelant à la haine
ce mode de poursuite permettra
d'apporter la réponse rapide nécessaire
qui fait aujourd'hui défaut à l'arsenal
pénal
il s'agit de répondre immédiatement aux
discours de haine qui prospère
aujourd'hui sur internet notamment parmi
nos jeunes et dont les auteurs tarde
trop souvent à être jugé cette
disposition
fruit d'une large consultation organisée
avec les professionnels du secteur de la
presse se fera en modifiant uniquement
le code de procédure pénale je me
félicite que la rédaction proposée est
amélioré par votre commission des loi
préserve sans ambiguïté les garanties
dont bénéficient les journalistes
je ne doute pas bien sûr de la qualité
de nos débats qui permettront sans doute
d'enrichir ce texte
j'estime essentiel absolument essentiel
pour garantir l'avenir de notre pacte
républicain
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux la
parole est maintenant ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports monsieur jean michel blanc
terre
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le sur les présidents des commissions
mesdames et rapporteur chers collègues
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je suis moi à mon tour très heureux de
présenter ce projet de loi dont
l'importance a été soulignée par les
précédents orateurs vous le savez tous
l'école est centrale pour l'enjeu qui
nous réunit ça a été rappelée à
l'instant par le garde des sceaux et on
ne le dira jamais assez
l'école est la colonne vertébrale de la
république
comme pour de nombreuses institutions de
la république cette institution a des
racines profondes compris dans la
monarchie et dans l' empire travail de
jules ferry à avant lui le travail de
guizot celui de victor duruy et donc la
généralisation progressive de
l'enseignement mais ces sept oeuvres de
jules ferry qui marque les esprits parce
que dès les années 1880 et donc même
avant la loi de 1905
on a évidemment un principe de laïcité
en germe explicites et implicites
je dirais qu l'implicite est encore plus
important puisque la généralisation du
savoir
c'est la généralisation et la
consolidation de la république l'école
de la république se présente comme fille
de la philosophie des lumières la
république et fille des lumières et
l'école et filles de la république ce
qui signifie très clairement qu'à chaque
fois que l'école s'éloigne de la
république
elle s'éloigne d'elle même et cela a pu
arriver et cela ne doit pas arriver
l'école doit sans cesse quel que soit le
statut de l'école dont on parle
l'école doit sans cesse être ramenés aux
valeurs de la république
je crois que ces idées là nous unissent
elles sont le socle de ce dont nous
avons à discuter sur le sujet scolaires
et la période actuelle nous le rappelle
particulièrement puisque la france se
distingue par son attachement pour
l'école l'école comme le socle pour nos
enfants
le socle pour notre société et bien au
travers de cette loi il s'agit de
compléter l'oeuvre législatives accompli
précédemment de la compléter non pas
parce qu'il faudrait tout réinventer
mais au contraire parce qu'il faut
apporter une pierre nouvelle
beaucoup de choses ont été faites dans
l'histoire de la république
je ne vais évidemment pas à les rappeler
maintenant et puis beaucoup de choses
ont pu être cette récemment parfois
lorsqu'on parle de ce projet de loi
j'entends certains me disent me dire
mais vous ne parlez pas tellement de
l'école publique vous ne parlez que de
l'instruction en famille et des écoles
hors contrat je voudrais d'emblée réfuté
cet argument pour dire tout simplement
que heureusement nous avons déjà
travaillé sur le premier sujet depuis
trois ans beaucoup a été fait pour
consolider la laïcité dans l'école de la
république je le rappelle en quelques
mots la création du conseil des sages de
la laïcité qui nous parle permet d'avoir
un corps de norme de référence pour
l'ensemble de l'éducation nationale et
ce de manière vivante parce que cette
institution présidée par madame snapper
sans arrêt dialogue avec le terrain pour
apporter des réponses concrètes aux
problèmes qui se posent
la création des équipes valeurs de la
république dans chaque rectorat de
france qui permettent d'aller
concrètement sur le terrain chaque fois
qu'ils devraient demander et donc alors
même que parfois certains décrivent
l'éducation nationale comme une
institution habité par l'esprit du pas
de vagues comme on dit parfois
rapidement cela ne doit plus être cela
n'est pas vrai cela est quelque chose
que j'ai voulu contrecarrer
dès que j'ai pris mes fonctions par des
actes concrets même si bien entendu il
reste bien des choses à améliorer
le travail a été fait sur l'école de là
sur l'école de la république
il reste du travail à faire sur l'école
hors contrat et sur l'instruction en
famille il ya quatre femmes quatre
façons d'être scolarisés en france
l'école publique école privée sous
contrat
l'école privée hors contrat et
l'instruction en famille et ses deux
derniers sujets qui sont
particulièrement traités par cette loi
tout simplement parce que c'est les deux
brèches dans lesquelles se sont
engouffrés ce que nous appelons
désormais le séparatisme parce que en
effet ce sont des brèches parce que en
effet il ya des vides juridiques
alors là aussi nous n'avons pas chômé et
vous le savez mieux que personne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
puisque c'est au sénat à partir de la
proposition de ouaga tel qu'un travail
important a été fait sur les écoles hors
contrat et cette loi énormément
d'importance aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
nous permet d'être efficace sur le sujet
de l'empêchement d'ouverture des cols
hors contrat parce que leur projet ne
serait pas conforme aux principes de la
république
il ya donc la loi gatel qui est un jalon
très important depuis que nous l'avons
mise en oeuvre nous voyons qu'il ya
encore un pas à franchir et le ministre
de l'intérieur ya fait référence
c'est le fait que nous devons savoir
mieux fermer les écoles hors contrat une
fois qu'elles sont ouvertes
parce que en effet il ya des abus est
parce qu en effet au travers des
facilités l'école hors contrat
il y à des institutions clairement
visées séparatistes qui se sont
installées et donc nous devons fermer
plus efficacement dans le futur grâce
aux dispositions du projet de loi qui
vous est présentée et puis il y à
l'instruction en famille le fameux
article 21 je n'ignore pas que c'est
celui qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
à juste titre c'est normal qu'il soit
beaucoup discuté en même temps ça ne
doit pas occulter l'importance des
autres dispositions l'instruction en
famille est interdite dans plusieurs
pays d'europe l'allemagne la suède
l'espagne par exemple jamais la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme il ya
vu un quelconque problème notre visé
n'est pas d'interdire l'instruction en
famille et beaucoup nombreuses familles
qui pratiquent l'instruction en famille
ne doivent pas se sentir menacé par cet
article 21 tout simplement parce que
nous avons prévu un régime d'exception
qui est aujourd'hui suffisamment large
pour permettre à l'instruction en
famille normal de continuer à s'exercer
néanmoins nous avons voulu être efficace
face aux abus et comme l'a rappelé
ministre de l'intérieur
chaque fois que nous démantelons
actuellement des structures clandestines
de scolarité la moitié des enfants et
même un peu plus son soi-disant en
instruction en famille nous voyons bien
qu'il ya là un véhicule pour le
séparatisme notamment celui de
l'islamisme fondamentalistes ça peut
être aussi d'ailleurs d'autres formes de
séparatisme comme différentes sectes
nous en débattrons beaucoup évidemment
et ce sujet est essentielle enfin je
voudrais conclure en parlant du sport
c'est l'occasion de souligner
l'importance de la réunion du ministère
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports dans un esprit lui aussi
très républicain de vision complète de
l'enfant est bien la disposition de
l'article 25 doit nous permettre d'être
plus efficace grâce aux contrats
d'engagement républicains dont il a déjà
été question à cette tribune
nous en parlerons plus en détail mais ce
que je voudrais dire pour conclure c'est
que ce qui vous est présentée ici je
crois pouvoir le dire
pour l'ensemble des dispositions qui
valent pour l'éducation la jeunesse et
les sports
ce ne sont pas seulement des
dispositions visant à défendre la
république c'est bien entendu le point
central mais aussi et ça va ensemble des
dispositions pour défendre les droits de
l'enfant les droits de l'enfant
rejoignent les principes de la
république
et c'est ce que l'on voit tout
particulièrement au travers de ce projet
de loi je vous remercie
merci monsieur me disent je vais
maintenant donner la parole aux
rapporteurs
tout d'abord madame jacqueline eustache
brinio rapporteur de la commission des
lois
vous avez la parole un reporter
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président la
commission des lois
madame et messieurs les co-rapporteurs
n'oublie pas les messieurs ce qu'ils ont
été oubliés et chers collègues
voici un peu plus d'un an que le
président la république a placé le terme
de séparatisme au coeur de notre débat
public
une prise de conscience tardive mais
nécessaire nous n'avions pas attendu
cette parole présidentielle tout
bienvenue qu'elle soit pour prendre la
mesure du défi auquel fait face notre
république
de nombreux travaux au sénat se sont
penchés sur la question du terrorisme
sur la radicalisation sur la place des
cultes dans notre pays
le dernier en date ces travaux étaient
menées par la commission d' enquête sur
la lutte contre la radicalisation
islamiste et les moyens de la combattre
nous avions fait collectivement le
constat de la nécessité de lutter contre
la volonté d'une minorité active de
soumettre à des normes prétendu
religieuse la vie de nos concitoyens
cette pression s'exerce sur les jeunes
sur les femmes surtout ce que l'on veut
assigner à résidence géographique ou
identitaire pour lutter contre ce
phénomène
nous avions formulé plusieurs
propositions que nous sommes heureux de
retrouver en nombre dans ce texte
composé dans son immense majorité
d'anciens élus locaux le sénat mesure la
réalité de l'islam radical
et de ses conséquences sur la remise en
cause de l'unité nationale le texte tel
que nous vous le présentons est le fruit
du travail de la commission des lois et
de la commission culture de diagnostic
de terrain et de large concertation avec
les élus les représentants des cultes
des universitaires des intellectuels et
le monde associatif
je souhaite rapidement vous présenter
les modifications adoptées par la
commission des lois sur les articles que
j'ai plus particulièrement suivie
s'agissant des services publics
l'essentiel du texte réside dans la
codification de la jurisprudence et
portent peu d'innovation il entend
inscrire dans la loi le respect des
principes de neutralité et de laïcité
des personnes chargées d'un service
public
quelles que soient les modalités
d'organisation de celle ci nous
débattrons du champ d'application de ce
principe et des personnes auxquelles il
doit s'appliquer
ce débat me semble important il porte
sur deux catégories de personnes
la première est celle les personnes qui
participent de manière occasionnelle aux
services publics
la commission des lois considèrent
qu'elles ne sont pas toutes dans la même
situation et qu'il est en pratique
impossible de leur imposer à tout la
même exigence de neutralité cependant et
nous le verrons nous sommes favorables à
elle au bout de la logique pour
certaines d'entre elles qui
interviennent dans le cadre très
particulier de l'école la seconde
catégorie de personnes est celle des
usagers des services publics
ici encore nous devons être réalistes
imposer la neutralité des usagers au
service public n'a pas de sens mais à l
inverse et nous aurons ce débat
interdire dans certains cadres délimiter
le port de signes religieux
ostentatoires fait sens
s'agissant ensuite des mesures relatives
au respect des droits des personnes et à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
il nous a rassemblé nécessaire d'être
efficace sur ces questions essentielles
et sensible de poser des principes
clairs et de ne pas nous contenter de
mots nous allons supprimer certains
articles tels que l'article 13 et en
avait pas en avant précise et d'autres
sur les certificat de virginité ou les
mariages forcés
s'agissant enfin de la police des cultes
l'actualisation de ces mesures est
bienvenue et nous la soutenons
nous sommes cependant nous ne sommes
cependant attachés à préserver la
responsabilité du ministre des cultes et
avons rétabli l'article 35 de la loi
1905 en prévoyant un quantum de peine
actualiser et renforcer enfin nous
approuvons le principe d'une nouvelle
mesure de fermeture administrative des
lieux de culte en cas de provocation à
la haine ou à la violence et nous avons
porté sa durée à trois mois tout en
précisant les raisons pouvant conduire à
cette extension
parallèlement nous souhaitons
caractérisé davantage les locaux annexes
au lieu de culte qu'il sera possible de
faire mais s'il existe des raisons
sérieuses de penser qu'ils seraient
utilisés pour faire échec à l'exécution
de la mesure de fermeture du lieu de
culte
ces mesures pragmatiques utiles sont de
véritables avancées dans la lutte
quotidienne contre le séparatisme nous
pouvons espère trouver ensemble les
formulations les plus adéquates
ce texte donne l'occasion de donner aux
services de l'état des clés et des
outils nécessaires pour lutter contre le
séparatisme au service de la république
et de ceux ci manquait la laïcité mais
ce texte ne suffira pas à construire
l'immense remparts que nous avons à
bâtir tous ensemble il n'en sera que la
première pierre qui donnent leur bord
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant donner la parole
notre collègue dominique verrière
rapporteur de la commission des lois
avait la parole à porter merci monsieur
le président monsieur président et
monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues rapporteur mes chers collègues
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur
l'objectif premier de ce texte était de
lutter contre le séparatisme
mais comment leak ton contre le
séparatisme
remettons-nous si vous le voulez bien
dans une perspective historique
notre révolution à 230 ans la république
est une jeune fille au vu de notre
histoire et il faut l'avouer ces
principes n'ont pas été appréciée de
tous à sa création et qui a combattu le
plus énergiquement sa mise en oeuvre
l'église catholique et de 1789 à 1907
nous n'avons cessé de légiférer pour
arriver à ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
un état laïc qui ne reconnaît aucune
religion au sens où il les reconnaît
tout et l'apaisement avec l'église
catholique
il vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre
n'intervient qu'en 1923 1923 près de 140
ans de disputes avec un état étranger
qui ne souhaitait pas nous voir sortir
de sa coupe le vatican en 1860 le pop
pie-ix spécifié dans le syllabus les 80
propositions qualifiées erreur
principale de notre temps que rome
tiendrait évidemment pour airetik et
c'est à dire que celui qui les a qui les
accepteraient devrait être adjugée sa
foi quelles étaient ses erreurs
la prépotence du pouvoir civil la libre
recherche de la vérité
les droits de la conscience la
neutralité scolaire le droit civil le
suffrage universel
la police des cultes la science la
liberté de la presse et de la parole est
naturellement l'indépendance de la
morale et de la philosophie vis-à-vis du
catholicisme lorsque j'ai lu cela dans
le rapport d'aristide briand cela
vraiment raisonner en moins
nous ne faisons donc que continuer le
combat il ne s'agit plus aujourd'hui du
catholicisme mais le syllabus n'a que
160 ans et ce n'est pas une éternité et
comment la république s'est elle
défendue par des lois celle de 1901 puis
de 1905 et enfin de 1907 en 1900 waldeck
rousseau qui fit voter la loi de 1901
disait il s'agit ensuite par la même loi
de faire face aux périls qui n'est du
développement continu dans une société
démocratique d'un organisme qui tend à
introduire dans l'état sous le voile
spécieux d'un affreux d'un institut
religieux un corps politique dont le but
est de parvenir d'abord à une
indépendance absolue est successivement
à l'usurpation de toute autorité
la loi de 1905 se profilait déjà pour
établir clairement la séparation des
églises et de l'état c'est à dire du
spirituel et du temporel
je ne résiste pas à l'envié de vous
préciser que c'est à auxerre qui emile
combes annonça le 4 septembre 1904 ce
projet de loi
ce rapide historique a pour but de
montrer que ceux que nous combattons
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas nouveau et qu'il
est temps de rappeler à ceux qui n'ont
pas vécu cette longue histoire de
séparation du spirituel et du temporel
ce qu'est notre culture ce que veut dire
notre laïcité concept tellement français
la création de la république c'est loin
la loi de 1905
c'est loin dans notre monde actuel qui
tente à oublier son histoire
la laïcité est notre modèle il est temps
de le rappeler en france nous ne prenons
pas à dieu ce qui lui appartient mais
nous ne sommes pas prêts à lâcher ce qui
t'a appartient à césar c'est pourquoi un
projet de loi qui pousse les
associations cultuelles à respecter le
régime de 1905 est utile c'est pourquoi
un projet de loi qui permet de contrôler
les fonds étrangers et donc les
influences étrangères
tout comme nous nous sommes toujours
battus contre l' influence du vatican
est utile notre commission monsieur le
ministre n'a donc pas bousculer votre
texte mais il l'a enrichie pour le
rendre plus efficace et si je viens de
rappeler notre combat anciens avec les
cultes n'oublions pas que 1905 nous
oblige à la liberté de culte est
importante et ce contrôle ne peut
s'exercer de façon trop tatillonne sans
trahir nos propres principes
nul ne doit être inquiété pour ses
opinions même religieuses
ainsi avons-nous fait le choix de
desserrer aneto en permettant aux
préfets de s'intéresser plus directement
aux associations dont le fonctionnement
l'interpellent lors du renouvellement de
la déclaration cultuelle ce qui sera
d'ailleurs probablement plus conformes
avec les moyens dont il dispose en
conclusion ce texte n'est probablement
pas suffisant mais il est nécessaire et
j'espère donc que nos débats viendront
encore l'enrichir et que les principes
de notre république en sortirons
réellement renforcée merci madame le
rapporteur
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication monsieur stéphane pie noir
[Applaudissements]
j'avais la parole monsieur le rapporteur
ce président messieurs les ministres
mesdames les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues courage et lucidité
telles étaient les derniers mots du
rapport de jean pierre robin en 2004 sur
les signes manifestation religieuse dans
les établissements scolaires 10
inspecteurs généraux de l'éducation
nationale pointait déjà la montée du
phénomène religieux dans les quartiers
notamment chez les jeunes ce qui leur
valut d'être rapidement accès
d'islamophobe sans céder à une
généralisation
les constats révélé dans des
établissements scolaires constituaient
les signes avant coureurs d'une
véritable lame de fond dans notre pays
dont l'école recevait déjà légumes
évolution religieuse menant à une
islamisation de certains quartiers
régression de la condition féminine
contestation pédagogique déscolarisation
suspecte ambiguïté voir complaisance de
certaines collectivités
dix sept ans plus tard je m'interroge
sur les contours de la mission
législative qui nous est confiée je peux
reconnaître une forme de courage au
moins dans les mots au président de la
république qui annonçait le 2 octobre
dernier aux mureaux vouloir combattre le
séparatisme islamistes cette idéologie
qui veut imposer les lois d'une religion
à celle de notre république s'illustrera
de manière dramatique
quatorze jours plus tard avec
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie mais un
combat nécessite des armes et je doute
de la lucidité des auteurs de ce projet
de loi tant les moyens envisagés semble
limité au regard de l'ampleur et de la
preuve profondeur du phénomène la tumeur
islamistes qui se propage au coeur de
notre république a été ciblé homebrew
nous aurons tous je crois la difficulté
du protocole nécessaires à son
éradication la finesse du traitement à
mettre en place
au lieu de cela ce projet de loi nous
propose d'irradier l'ensemble du corps
en espérant que l'un de ses rayons par
un phénomène stochastique atteindra sa
cible ainsi la principale disposition
dans le domaine de l'éducation
consisterait à modifier en profondeur
les modalités de l'instruction en
famille
cette voie d'instructions qui existe
depuis trois républiques
cela constitue une grossière confusion
pour ne pas dire à l'amalgamme
malhonnête en faisant de l'instruction
en famille une sorte de complices de ce
séparatisme alors qu aucun élément
factuel de corrélation de mazet ne m'a
été présenté au cours des auditions
outre le risque constitutionnel le
régime d'autorisation voulue par le
gouvernement instaure une suspicion
généralisé à l'endroit des familles qui
pratique lui f de manière régulière
ce n'est pas acceptable et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons supprimé
l'article 21 ans commission pour
répondre à la problématique des enfants
hors radars et des déscolarisations
suspecte la commission de la culture a
adopté des mesures de détection
différencié pour fermer les brèches donc
quelques instants par malignement en
détournant l'ietf sa fonction première
permettre à chaque enfant de disposer du
légitime droit à l'instruction et
d'autres priorités c'est pourquoi nous
avons créé des cellules haddock permis
de renforcer les contrôles des
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale ou
encore interdits au f aux familles dont
les enfants ont fréquenté une école
clandestine
nous espérons sincèrement que le
gouvernement considère a in fine est que
cette démarche est à la fois plus
protectrice et plus efficace avec
l'école le sport et l'autre entrée
privilégiée du séparatisme islamistes
comme l'a montré le rapport de la
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste dont jacqueline
eustache brinio était rapporteur en 2019
du licencié à la fédération tous les
acteurs du sport doivent se sentir
concernés
c'est pourquoi la commission a souhaité
renforcer la promotion des principes de
la république dans le milieu sportif et
l'octroi de subventions ou la mise à
disposition d'équipements sportifs
publics sera conditionné à l'engagement
de respecter les principes de la
république
enfin quant à l'absence de
l'enseignement supérieur dans le spectre
de ce texte
j'hésite entre le manque de courage et
l'absence de lucidité
l'exposé des motifs de ce texte
mentionne pourtant explicitement je cite
le travail de sape dan entrisme
communautarisme insidieux qui concerne
de multiples sphères dont les services
publics
sept ans triste communautariste
invitante d'enlever débat public
contournant le sens des mots des choses
des valeurs et de la mesure alors que de
très récentes déclarations
ministérielles reconnaissent l'existence
d'une problématique d'entrisme
islamistes à l'université ce texte
oublie un service public celui de
l'enseignement supérieur
il faudra nous expliquer pourquoi et
comment l'université serait en dehors de
notre société pour ne pas subir comme
ailleurs les assauts du fléau islamistes
loin d'être un terreau d'une
extraordinaire fertilité les campus
doivent instaurer les conditions de son
éradication
nous avons donc introduit l'interdiction
des prières dans les lieux inadaptés
conditionné l'octroi de locaux au
respect des principes de la république
est précise et l'exercice de la liberté
d'expression pour que ne soit pas
entravé la mission même de l'université
l'enseignement la recherche le débat la
confrontation d'idées par des
agissements souvent violents de quelques
groupuscules chacun connaît cette
formule de françois poussard quand la
borne est franchie il n'est plus de
limites
n'oublions pas la suite et la première
faute aux fautes nous invite je remercie
merci je suis rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant donner la parole le
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances monsieur albéric de
montgolfier la parole m merci monsieur
président du sénat mais si elle est
ministre s'étendant de la commission des
lois mesdames les rapporteurs sur
collègues
la commission des finances s'est en
effet saisi pour avis de quatre articles
les articles 10 11 12 et 36 qui ont
trait à son champ de compétence et il
faut noter que ces articles finalement
notre cas de callian assez ténu avec la
lutte contre le séparatisme et le
respect des principes de la république
jeu comme jeudi en commission même si
l'article se justifie d'ailleurs nous
allons globalement les approuver c est
ce qui fait au fond la res cription dans
ce projet de loi consacré à la lutte
contre les séparatistes ne semble
quelque peu opportuniste
ainsi les articles 10 à 12 du projet de
loi concerne aussi bien
l'encadrement des avantages fiscaux
attribuées aux associations que
l'encadrement le régime
vous le savez en france les associations
comme les fondations comme les fonds de
dotation bénéficient d'un régime fiscal
privilégié celui du mécénat qui permet
de délivrer des reçus fiscaux permettant
ainsi aux contribuables de bénéficier
d'une réduction d'impôt au titre lors de
l'heure dont il est aujourd'hui ce
régime très peu contrôlé très peu
contrôlées même s'il faut le reconnaître
la commission des finances est dans son
rôle que le montant la dépense fiscale
est importante puisque nous avons chaque
année 1 milliard 500 millions d'euros de
coûts pour la réduction de la peau sur
le revenu ça concerne un grand nombre de
foyers fiscaux en france 5 millions cinq
cent mille foyers fiscaux et nous avons
à peu près 800 millions d'euros chaque
année au titre de la réduction d'impôt
pour les sociétés donc du mécénat
société qui concerne soixante dix sept
mille entreprises
l'article 10 du projet de loi qui nous
occupe vise à instaurer une nouvelle
procédure de contrôle celle du contrôle
de l'éligibilité de l'organisme au
régime du mécénat
gérald darmanin on n'a pas un instant je
dois rappeler
faut-il le faire que les associations
supplée l'état dans de nombreux domaines
on peut penser au secours des plus
démunis on peut penser aux associations
d aide humanitaire qui agissent
particulièrement en ce contexte de crise
il faudrait donc que ce projet de loi en
particulier ses articles fiscaux ne
conduisent pas à faire peser des
contraintes trop lourde sur ces
organismes sans but lucratif et je pense
notamment aux plus petites associations
qui repose sur le bénévolat ce point
d'équilibré je crois nous a constamment
guidée avec les rapporteurs de la
commission des lois
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
été conduits à proposer le report de
l'entrée en vigueur de cet article au
1er janvier 2022
en effet il y à un risque celui que les
associations sans but lucratif ou les
organismes sans but lucratif afin de se
prémunir contre les contrôles qui seront
instaurées à la suite de cette loi
voudrait demander plus fréquemment le
recours à une procédure qu'on appelle
celle du rescrit mécénat qui se permet
d'interroger l'administration fiscale
est ainsi de savoir si on était et
lisible au bénéfice de l'éligibilité des
reçus fiscaux et ses recours au mécénat
ou serait ce au pardon rescrit mécénat
pourrait être d'autant plus massif que
comme la cour des comptes l'a souligné
dans un récent référé le régime du droit
où la doctrine fiscale plutôt relatives
aux conditions d'éligibilité au mécénat
n'est pas vraiment stabilisé
il ya beaucoup doctrine ce sont des
critères qui se reposent sur des cas
d'espèce et j'espère monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement sera laissé
ce temps supplémentaire que nous
resterons pour que les associations
puissent s'adapter et que le régime de
peut-être de la doctrine puis se
stabiliser donc nous soutenons
évidemment l'instauration de ce contrôle
il n'y a pas d'opposition de principe
c'est bien sûr destiné autant à protéger
la générosité des contribuables que
l'état mais il ne s'agit pas de rendre
les choses plus difficiles pour les plus
petites associations l'article le 11e
créé quant à lui une obligation pour les
organismes sans but lucratif de déclarer
chaque année à l'administration fiscale
le montant global des dons à des
versements dont ils ont bénéficié
on a une sous le reconnaître assez loin
du séparatisme parce qu'elle a concerné
toutes les associations monsieur le
ministre est pas les seuls de la gestion
cultuelle mais ça vise aussi à reporter
pourquoi pas à mieux piloter la dépense
publique et ne semble que cette
obligation créé peut être un risque
d'alourdissement administratif
j'en connais que et c'est l'obligation
sera d'autant plus légère qui lira une
plateforme numérique par étendre
déclarés chaque année aux associations
il faudra veiller que c'est plate forme
soient mises en oeuvre dans les délais
et je suis un petit peu inquiet la
réponse le dg fip qui nous dit que ça
sera progressivement mis en service
c'est la raison du report de nous a
proposé au 1er janvier 2022 pour
permettre aux gouvernements de s'adapter
d'avoir le portail pleinement
opérationnel d'ici là l'article 12
élargi la liste des infractions
susceptibles d'entraîner la suspension
des avantages fiscaux haute idée dont là
aussi les infractions ont concerné vous
le savez ils sont aujourd'hui peu limité
c'est celle qui fait peser la menace
grave sur la société contre le
terrorisme le blanchiment d'argent et
donc le nombre de condamnations est
aujourd'hui extrêmement réduits mois 200
personnes parents et je terminerai avec
l'article 46 qui concerne le droit
d'opposition de trac fin c'est à dire la
capacité de bloquer une association en
commission nous sommes revenus sur
dispositions adaptées l'assemblée
nationale qui renvoyait à un décret les
conditions dans lesquelles les
assujettis à ne pas répondre à certaines
opérations ont dit victime monsieur les
ministes pas d'opposition de principe
mais un souhait de préserver la vie
associative qui est très largement
concerné bien au delà de ce texte merci
beaucoup
bien nous allons maintenant passer à la
discussion de la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
monsieur le président patrick kanner et
les membres du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains ont déposé
une motion qui porte le numéro 38 et qui
tenta ou poser la question préalable au
texte en discussion
je vais donc donner la parole aux
présidents patrick kanner pour dix
minutes monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres je salue au passage la mafia
pas qui nous a quittés may hamm les
rapporteurs messieurs les rapporteurs
oui oui mais je n'étais pas du tout
ironique
c'était pas du tout ironique c'était
pour la saluer réellement monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
chers collègues nous avons cherché en
vain
dans ce projet de loi l' équilibre du
discours des mureaux prononcé par le
président de la république le 2 octobre
2020 plus personne ne s'en étonne le
président qui se prétend de droite et de
gauche marche finalement sur la seule
jambe qui n'ai jamais eu la jambe droite
celle qui confond autorités avec
autoritarisme fermeté avec fermeture
non nous ne cédons pas à la facilité qui
se contenterait d'une société dans
laquelle chaque communauté
cohabiteraient même pacifiquement côte à
côte sur un modèle anglo saxon
perpétuant des différences de droit nous
préférons créer les conditions du
rassemblement où peuvent s'exprimer
toutes les croyances dans notre cité
républicaine la seule loi qui vaille est
celle que les femmes et les hommes se
donnent à eux mêmes la laïcité ne
consiste pas à nier la quête spirituelle
chez l'être humain mais a refusé au nom
de l'unité et de la liberté le statut
politique dominateur que contrerait
l'ascendant d'une religion sur la
puissance publique
ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui c'est
l'écart entre l'idéal républicain
proclamé par le président de la
république et ce projet de loi
non l'exécutif ne peut pas dire comme
aristide briand son temps que ce texte
est une loi de liberté
sur le plan économique les profs
d'ultralibéralisme de ce gouvernement ne
sont plus à démontrer certes mais sur le
plan des libertés
en revance nous ne voyons qu'un
affaiblissement de la conquête les plus
chers cette loi est une loi de
contraintes
une addition de mesures d'ordre public
nouveau délit au pénal contrôle des
associations fermeture des lieux de
culte un tiers des articles du texte
instaure des procédures de contrôle et
plus d'un quart défini des peines
d'emprisonnement même le défenseur des
droits vous en fais le reproche sont
pourtant concerné la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité la loi de 1901 sur les
associations les lois de 1882 sur
l'éducation la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse déjà abîmée par le
fameux article 24 de la loi de sécurité
globale
certes des avancées importantes sont
faites en faveur du droit des femmes je
vous en donne acte mais pour le reste
c'est une loi de contrôle de police de
répression ce n'est pourtant pas en
réglementant les cultes alex et qu'on
parviendra au but
la laïcité mais chaque collègue n'est
pas l'ennemie de la religion c'est un
cadre c'est une liberté la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire c'est
affirmer avec hugo que l'état doit être
chez lui et l'église chez elle dès que
nous sentons l'expression d'une
prétendue laïcité de combat contre la
religion et non contre le fanatisme nous
la combattons dès que la religion est
manipulé par des intégristes qui ne
souhaitent pas que les convictions de
leurs coreligionnaires soit compatible
avec la république nous la combattons
également mais pour la combattre il ne
suffit pas d'employer la contrainte
l'exposé des motifs de ce projet de loi
énonce je cite la république demande une
adhésion de tous les citoyens qui en
composent le corps
je ne suis pas fin psychologue mais
croyez-vous que l'adhésion s'obtiennent
à coups de boutoir je ne le crois pas il
nous faut convaincre et non multiplier
d'absurde prohibition l'universel doit
se désirer nous regrettons que ce projet
de loi ne traite que des conséquences du
phénomène de radicalisation et dans les
causes
le phénomène dont nous parlons dépasse
la question économique et social mais
elle n'est pas hors du social il y à un
séparatisme prêchée par des religieux
radicaux il y à un séparatisme aussi
créé par le sentiment d'abandon de
certains territoires
le premier se nourrit d'ailleurs du
second c'est pourquoi un double
mouvement est nécessaire lutter contre
le rejet de la république mais aussi
lutter contre le rejet dans la
république derrière jaurès nous disons
que les combat laïque et social sont
indissociables pour nous socialistes
le président de la république a pourtant
dit je cite
partout où la république ne donne plus
d'avenir
n'attendez pas que ses enfants l'aiment
malheureusement mais quel avenir post il
rêvait de devenir millionnaire traverser
la rue trou pour trouver un travail et
s'acheter un costume le fameux
ruissellement est resté malheureusement
pour beaucoup d'entre nous une réelle
chimère la contestation de la république
se nourrit de ces signes d'hostilité de
rélégation qu'adresse l'état il faut
s'interroger sur le fait qu'une partie
de nos concitoyennes et le nos
concitoyens une infime partie rappelons
le se détournent de notre modèle de
société aussi facilement les discours
hostiles à la république prospère le
plus souvent dans des quartiers
ghettoïsés là où nous avons construit
notre propre séparatisme là où se
concentre la misère et la d re election
des quartiers où la promesse
républicaine n'est pas tenue des
quartiers ou recul service public où ce
recul laisse place à des organisations
privées parfois religieuse la question
n'est plus de savoir s'il faut moins
d'état ou mieux d'état un peu par ci
moins par la non il faut plus d'état
beaucoup plus d'état partout dans son
rôle providentiel il n'y a rien dans ce
projet de loi sur le volet social
rien n'est là pour lutter contre les
discriminations pour renforcer le tissu
associatif notamment l'éducation
populaire
fragilisé par la suppression des emplois
aidés au début du quinquennat
rien sur l'emploi le logement ou la
politique de la ville rien sur les
services publics en tant que telle ni
sur le déficit de cohésion territoriale
rien sur les structures d'accueil ni sur
l'évolution de notre modèle
dégration rien qui en somme ne
correspond à notre conception de la
concorde civile
ce n'est pourtant pas faute pour le
gouvernement de l'avoir maintes fois
promis nous partageons pourtant le
diagnostic il existe un problème que
nous ne nions pas oui il y à des réseaux
religieux qui s'infiltrent de façon
organisée dans la société en france et
dans une partie du monde un projet
politico religieux qui contestent nos
valeurs démocratiques
un projet qui vise à persuader certains
de nos concitoyens de se soustraire aux
lois de la république
cela peut se manifester par la
déscolarisation des enfants par une
communautarisation de pratiques
sportives ou associatives en général pas
des démonstrations de fois à l'intérieur
l'entreprise même chargée d'une mission
de service public
malheureusement nous aussi comme vous
nous le constatons messieurs les
ministres
nous connaissons le visage du fanatisme
ma famille politique n'a jamais fait
preuve de complaisance ou de
compromission lors des attentats qui ont
émaillé le quinquennat précédent mais
nous acceptons que le défi reste encore
à relever sans jambes sans angélisme
sans amalgame sans ambiguïté face à ces
forces centrifuges
alors oui certaines dispositions
auraient pu emporter notre adhésion des
sanctions plus sévères ou des mécanismes
de contrôle plus efficace des
financements peuvent produire des effets
bénéfiques mais pas seul pas seul ce
n'est pas comme cela qu'on confortera
les principes de notre république il est
facile al'approche d'échéances
électorales importantes de ressusciter
les passions tristes
en pénétrant sur le terrain du
séparatisme
le président de la république veut
apporter la preuve qu'ils l'udc
concrètement il n'est pas naïf il est
vrai qu'il est régulièrement accusé par
la droite et l'extrême droite d'en faire
trop peu sur le sujet moi je ne sais pas
si l'extrême droite se ramollit ou si le
gouvernement s'affermit toujours est il
que sur le sujet qui nous anime
aujourd'hui on ne distingue plus guère
la copie de l'original après la vaine
polémique sur l'ensauvagement supposée
de la société française
les rayons halal dans les supermarchés
le floutage des interventions de police
et un essai personnel parsemé
d'approximations historique
voici revenu chez le ministre de
l'intérieur avec tambours et trompettes
pour expliquer aux électeurs de droite
que le bulletin macron sera plus utile
que celui d'un candidat et l'eire face à
la candidate du front national
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre aurait-il d'obédience
sondagière avec vous monsieur le
ministre les choses sans simple
finalement soit on est contre le
terrorisme soit on est pour l'islam au
gauchisme comme il doit être reposant de
voir les choses
à travers cette vision binaire et
simplificatrice nous ne souhaitons pas
participer à cette hystérisation du
débat nous ne céderons pas à la facilité
qui consiste à utiliser des abstractions
pour frapper les esprits dans une
période où la politique est dominée par
des objectifs de communication
tel est le sens de cette question
préalable déposée par le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et en conséquence
mes chers collègues je vous laisse
méditer cette phrase de clemenceau
prononcé ici même à ce plateau le 9
avril 1916 inutile
il est inutile de demander une loi pour
avoir l'air de vouloir faire ce que l'on
aurait pu faire jusqu'à présent
sans aucun texte nouveau à répète pour
bien longtemps
j'ai encore un peu de temps il est
inutile de demander une loi pour avoir
l'air de vouloir faire ce qu'on aurait
pu faire je pourrais même dire ce qu'on
aurait dû le faire jusqu'à présent
sans aucun texte nouveau mes chers
collègues je vous invite
je vous invite à voter cette question
préalable
parfait la parole est à monsieur
grosperrin contre la motion madame la
présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
rapporteur
nous proposons donc le rejet de la
motion des pauses déposé par le
président de cannes air et les membres
du groupe socialiste écologique est
républicain et a si bien sûr la
poursuite de la délibération sur le
projet de loi comportant le respect des
principes de la république
les éléments de l'objet de la motion
peuvent surprendre
il s'appuie sur une référence quasi
mythique au discours des mureaux du 2
octobre 2020 prononcé par le président
de la république pour considérer que le
projet de loi qui nous est proposé n'est
pas fidèle et donc n'est pas fidèle à je
cite l'écosystème de notre modèle il est
paradoxal d'accorder une telle foi aux
promesses d'un discours si solennelle
qu'il fût il y a beaucoup de
complaisance ou de naïveté dans cet
argument nous avons tous observé depuis
2010 est l'angle mort que constituent
les questions régaliennes et l'autorité
de l'état pour le gouvernement
vous considérez monsieur le sénateur
kaner que c'est la question sociale qui
est cet angle mort que cette question
serait absente du texte qui nous est
proposée vous en déduisez l'inutilité de
l'examen du texte mais vous nous
permettez de nous retrouver ici dans ce
clivage gauche droite
en ce qui nous concerne nous ne sommes
pas dupes du calendrier politique et des
manipulations qu'il peut générer
nous n'avons pas été béat devant un
discours dont l' équilibre furtuna
satisfait que les admirateurs dans même
temps illusoire et inaccessible chers
collègues votre refus semble se réfugier
dans l'euphémisme s apparente un
véritable déni
il est tellement difficile à expliquer
qu'ils masquent mal bout contradictions
et votre gêne vous voyez des
insuffisances et des manques
nous y voyons le moyen d'échangé de
proposer de comploter conformément au
rôle du sénat sans excès ni caricature
ni surenchère en veillant au respect de
toutes les sensibilités de notre haute
assemblée en constatant réparant les
oublis volontaires de l'exécutif et les
insuffisances qu'il a programmé
oui votre motion peut s'apparenter un
déni chers collègues ce n'est pas nous
qui a strasbourg faisant preuve d'une
irresponsabilité coupable devant la
gérance d'un état étranger et fermons
les yeux sur leur refus de signer une
charte d'adhésion aux valeurs de la
république
ce n'est pas nous qui flirtons avec les
thèses de l'islamisme radical
ce n'est pas nous qui voulons financer
ceux qui refusent la république
enfin ce n'est pas nous qui soutenons
les dévoiements militants qui fétichise
la race quelques mois après l'assassinât
de samuel pâti au moment de
l'anniversaire de celui du colonel
arnaud beltrame le 24 mars 2018 à
carcassonne au moment où le souvenir de
tous les attentats islamistes et de ses
victimes nos ventes et nous poursuivra
longtemps
vos arguments de motion ne sont pas à la
hauteur de la situation que nous vivons
et que la crise comme il ne masque pas
chers collègues vous prétendez vous
appuyez sur un modèle idéal pour refuser
de les défendre
ou ce qui revient au même vous accepter
l'idée que ce modèle n'est plus capable
de se défendre lui-même le texte aborde
une multitude de sujets il est incomplet
et le gouvernement a peut-être à l'ama
qui tremble mais n'êtes-vous pas
concernées par les thèmes qu'il aborde
les services publics les discriminations
l'égalité pour lutter contre 10 fort
différentes formes d' inégalités
hommes-femmes moyenâgeuse la vie
associative
les discours de haine le libre exercice
du culte la préservation de l'ordre et
de l'autorité des pouvoirs publics
ne voyez vous pas que le sport qui s'est
longtemps cru
protégé de tout prosélytisme religieux
est désormais le théâtre de pratiques
inadmissibles et perd son rôle
d'intégrateur républicain ne voyez-vous
pas que l'éducation subi des pratiques
communautaristes qui portent gravement
atteinte à ces missions est la sécurité
de ses enseignants chers collègues nous
ne reconnaissons pas dans votre flux de
débattre l'identité laïque et
républicaine de certains d'entre vous
dont les partis ont géré la france un
mot résume votre gêne celui de
l'émancipation
il fut longtemps pour vous intégrer à
l'idéal républicain
une émancipation souvent partagé
porteuse de progrès de justice
votre motion montrent que vous vous
éloignez de votre propre histoire
vous êtes à la recherche de nouvelles
synthèses mobilisatrice pour votre
électorat ve vous devriez constater avec
nous qu'il faut s'émanciper soi même à
l'intérieur de la république et non pas
être sous l'emprise de l'extérieur d'une
religion totalitaire
chers collègues la république ce sont
les droits
ce sont des devoirs c'est une identité
c'est la sécurité pour tous
la france doit se battre contre tous les
séparatismes notamment le séparatisme
islamistes l'état ne cultivent aucun
racisme vis-à-vis des musulmans
nous ne laisserons personne l'affirmé le
racisme sous toutes ses formes doit être
combattu avec fermeté l'universalisme
des lumières nous unit pour faire
progresser des valeurs communes jamais
séparés il faut nommer les choses c'est
une des grandes difficultés de
l'exécutif pris à ses propres
contradictions
constatons ensemble que nous sommes bien
en présence d'une volonté hégémonique
religieuses et politiques
un communautarisme exacerbé dont
l'endoctrinement à la matrice est le
grignotage idéologique l'outil quotidien
une religion ne peut prétendre que ces
lois sont supérieures à celles de la
république
lutter contre les séparatismes n'est pas
lutter contre les religions celles ci
doivent rester de l'intimité de
conscience de chacun
nous ne nous laisserons pas enfermer ou
intimité et nous refuserons les débats
qui veulent corner risée les défenseurs
intransigeants de la république dans le
camp des archaïques des anciens ou des
conservateurs
aucun tabou culpabilisateur dans nos
réflexions l'intégration républicaine de
nouveau venu sur notre territoire dans
un contexte migratoire massif et non
maîtrisée pose des difficultés
insurmontables chacun le sait j'ai là
encore nous vous proposons la sagesse de
la lucidité devant les fêtes
chers collègues ne vous faites pas le
représentant d'une prétendue modernité
complaisante et serviles la
racialisation des problèmes sociaux l
assignation identitaire ne sont pas
l'avenir de notre nation
la france est le fruit d'une longue
histoire sa pensée d'une formidable
richesse c'est richesse aujourd'hui
mises à la disposition de
réinterprétations jusqu'à l'outrance qui
entendent modifier nos idéaux
les modèles venus d'ailleurs ne sont pas
les nôtres la laïcité n'est pas
négociable
mais cholet l'a si bien dit la france
est une personne cette personne doit
être respectée nous sommes un seul
peuple
il arrive même à ce peuple de croire
qu'il était unique qu'il est une
exception dans l'histoire universelle
il est aujourd'hui constituée en un état
de l'unité s'est faite par l'égalité
elle mérite républicain
notre tâche consiste à empêcher que ces
valeurs qui nous fonde se défasse chers
collègues la république et une volonté
est une profession elle est indivisible
elle est le rempart contre l'affirmation
bruyant de toutes les minorités
elle est fondée sur ce qui rapproche les
hommes et non pas sur ce qui les divise
défendons la république c'est la
poursuite de la promesse démocratique
est en jeu à défaut la france
coordonnera la puissance au déclin et
nos concitoyens ne l'accepterons pas
nous vous proposons donc de rejeter la
motion sur la question préalable
présentée par le président caennais ray
les membres du groupe socialiste
écologique et républicains je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai demandé à la commission qu'elle et
son avis sur cette question préalable
la présidente messieurs les ministres à
porter la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cette motion actifs à la
question préalable
la première raison c'est une question de
fond bien sûr que le texte ne règle pas
tous les problèmes n'aborde pas tous les
sujets j'ai le mérite de poser
clairement devant dans nos débats
les valeurs de la république et la lutte
contre le séparatisme deuxième troisième
sujet ou deuxième sujet plutôt c'est le
fait que la commission a travaillé des
rapporteurs ont analysé chacun des
articles fait des propositions et
veiller à la fois la protection des
libertés
bien évidemment mais aussi concourir au
projet de ce texte et enfin s'il
advenait que le sénat vote cette motion
eh bien il n'y aurait plus de débat et
le texte repartira d'ici privant ainsi
la haute assemblée de discussion et
d'avancées importantes donc un vide
défavorable du gouvernement le sait le
président caennais rond vous écoutant je
veux rappeler cette phrase du maréchal
d'assinie anaïs est quelqu'un qui
plantent deux glands qui achètent un mac
et qui attend j'ai pris un kader d'abord
je voudrais
vous dire que les leçons de social de
votre part sont un peu étonnante quand
vous étiez ministre j'ai constaté quand
j'étais maire la diminution sanglante
des ados ptic de la ville dans les
quartiers difficiles ceux là même que
vous dénoncez notamment par le
quadrillage inventé par vous même et par
monsieur d'amis qui ensuite a rejoint
notre collectivité de l'île préféré
diminuant ainsi ce qu'ils aident à
mixité sociale permettant un maximum un
maximum de dotation là où concentrer la
misère et après on s'étonne qu'il ya des
ghettos monsieur le président le cas
nerfs je ne sais pas en vous écoutant ce
qu'il ya de plus étonnant sans doute le
fait que vous pensez que ce texte est
vraiment horrible pour la république et
constater qu'à quelques semaines
seulement le groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale s'est abstenu de
façon constructive lundi notamment
l'orateur du groupe maurice vallot
peut-être s'est-il trompé peut-être
lui-même fait-il la course courte
échelle à madame le pen dans votre
propos sans doute le fait que vous
reprochez vous avez les leçons d'
extrémistes alors que vous même vous
alliez avec les pires extrémistes de
votre partie gauche de l'hémicycle vous
nous donner des leçons toute la journée
vous êtes capable de faire et c'est un
drame absolu me semble étaient pour la
démocratie le lien avec la france
insoumise non mais si ce n'était que tu
es parti communiste le savez bien que ce
n'est pas chez jamais douté un seul
instant que les communistes et
républicains madame la présidente vous
savez bien
mais l'alliance extrémistes évoqué pas
président caennais rend rien car france
insoumise me paraît étonnante
sans doute y at il des leçons de
république au sénat peut-être y at-il du
militantisme politique ailleurs mais
surtout vous ai passé monsieur kader la
gauche qui défend l'école publique où
est passée la gauche qui défend la
laïcité
où est passée la gauche qui pourrait
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques
cours d'année les élus municipaux qui
rêve qui réserve qui réserve qui réserve
des horaires spécifiques pour les femmes
pour les questions religieuses qui
organise des soirées un burqini et qui
permet à des candidats ou des élus de
considérer que quand on a une couleur de
peau à se taire où est passée la gauche
plutôt que de citer jaurès et de citer
clemenceau appliquée
soyez fidèles à manuel valls soyez
fidèles à dernière cazeneuve soyez
fidèles à clemenceau que vous avez cités
soyez fidèles h vêtements mais oui mais
je préfère avoir monsieur sarkozy que le
modèle que monsieur mélenchon monsieur
kader ne vous en déplaise et monsieur
kader monsieur kader pour ce soit pas
une pour que ce ne soit pas une private
joke
selon le bon dicton populaire vous qui
avez laissé partir les électeurs de
gauche au front national
vous le savez bien vous qui parce que
vous avez préféré la voix incroyable des
beaux salons parisiens et le terra nova
plutôt que d'écouter les peuples les
ouvriers monsieur kader dans notre
territoire dans notre territoire
monsieur kader quand on voit ce qu'on
voit quand on sait ce qu'on pense d'eux
cause de ce qu'on sait d'autres
territoires
et quand on a entendu ce qu'on a entendu
dans on a bien raison de penser ce qu'on
entend ça vous regarde bien
je vais maintenant donner la parole pour
les explications de vote d'abord madame
benbassa oui à on m'avait indiqué madame
benbassa si c'est monsieur bon temps je
donne la parole à monsieur contente
merci merci madame la présidente
oui effectivement nous sommes là
monsieur le monsieur le ministre il est
invraisemblable de pet de prétendre
conforter les prix les principes de la
république comme vous le disiez en les
bafouant ainsi en un seul texte mal
écrit alternant les dispositions inutile
et liberticide
quand ce n'est pas les deux à la fois
vous foulez aux pieds les grandes lois
fondatrices de la république française
d'abord la loi du 29 juillet 80 relative
à la liberté de la presse que vous
muselé en réintroduisant le funeste
article 24 masqué sous les traits cette
fois de l'article 18
la loi du 28 mai 1882 relative à
l'inscription obligatoire que vous
dévoyez en supprimant la liberté
d'instruction en famille
la loi du 1er juillet 1901 relative à la
liberté d'association que vous écraser
au mieux dans l'innommable lourdeurs
bureaucratiques au pire d'un serment
d'allégeance à la norme politiques
dominantes et enfin la loi du 9 décembre
105 relatives à la séparation de
l'église et de l'état vous entraver la
liberté de croire et de ne pas croire en
déployant des moyens de contrôle du
culte jamais vu jusque là monsieur le
ministre c'est loin on était bâtie par
le compromis républicain de la fin du
19e siècle qui enfin a permis
d'installer durablement la république
dans notre pays
ces lois ont été si parfaitement et si
bien écrite que leur colonne vertébrale
est resté inchangé depuis plus d'un
siècle
quelle arrogance quel mépris de vouloir
en modifier ainsi la substance sans
aucun mandat du peuple lisent et
relisent et les lettres persanes de
montesquieu il est quelquefois
nécessaire de changer certaines lois
mais le cas est rare et lorsqu'il arrive
il ne faut toucher que d'une main
tremblante
vos textes fait exactement l'averse
semblable à un marteau qui chassent une
mouche
il manquera inévitablement sa cible et
causera d'inutiles destruction il ne
ressort ce aucun des principes
républicains que sont la liberté
l'égalité et la fraternité
il ne répond à aucune des problématiques
qui déchire le pacte social et
nourrissent le communautarisme
exit la mitis la mixité sociale dans le
logement exit la mixité scolaire existe
tout ce qui permettrait de lutter contre
le principal forme de séparatisme qui
gangrène notre pays
le séparatisme social et je vais citer
jean jaurès parce que vous l'appréciez
le déclarer déjà je n'ai jamais séparé
la république des idées de justice
sociale sans laquelle il n'est qu'un mot
voilà le seul et unique chemin pour
conforter la république a fortiori quand
la france compte 10 millions de pauvres
et semble se plaît préparer à un
confinement dramatique
alors oui le groupe écologie solidarité
rite war votre à cette question
préalable
merci madame claude hermann madame la
présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la france est une république
indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale
et c'est bien par ses quatre
qualificatif que se définit notre
république et c'est bien avec la volonté
politique de répondre à ces quatre
qualificatif que nous construisons la
république
et que nous répondons aux besoins de
république dont ont besoin les femmes et
les hommes qui au quotidien vivent et
travaillent dans cette république
à l'heure où nous parlons d'éviter tout
séparatisme
à l'heure où nous parlons de rassembler
cette communauté citoyenne
permettez moi tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur d'éviter toute
stigmatisation des uns et des autres
toute stigmatisation de formation
politique qui que l'on soit d'accord ou
pas avec elle contribue inévitablement à
faire vivre le débat démocratique et
donc à faire république depuis 20 ans
dans notre pays
la laïcité est de plus en plus
instrumentalisée instrumentalisé non pas
pour permettre à chacun de vivre
librement et de vivre avec l'autre dans
cette liberté individuelle de conscience
et de croyance mais plutôt pour
stigmatiser et ne le cachons pas une
communauté au détriment des autres et
d'ailleurs votre projet de loi et c'est
en ceci que nous serons en désaccord
résume finalement toute cette
problématique sur la laïcité à travers
des questions principalement d'ordre
public
alors je ne ferai pas de citation je
n'évoquerai pas l'histoire parce que je
crois en une république vivante et
moderne une république vive anti moderne
mais qui s'incarne et qui n'oublie
jamais ses quatre qualificatif qui sont
inscrit dans notre constitution nous ne
les oublierons pas à travers tous nos
amendements
nous ne les oublierons pas à travers
toutes nos interventions sur articles et
les explications vote que nous ferons
parce qu'il n'ya pas ici ce qu'ils
défendraient ou combattre est plutôt le
fondamentalisme et ceux qui en seraient
les complices personne n'a de leçon ici
à recevoir notre groupe comme tant
d'autres à travers toute l'histoire les
ont combattues et combattront à les
combattre
nous voterons cette motion
métier soeur madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je m'inscrirai totalement dans
le droit fil de la déclaration de la
cuillère ban monsieur le ministre
s'il ya un sujet qui doit rassembler
pour lequel on doit s'écouter et où les
polémiques de bas étage sont vaines
c'est bien celui là nous nous honorons
avec patrick kanner d'être de ceux qui
ont des convictions politiques qui sont
attachés à un parti politique et qui ne
changent pas il y à des spécialistes du
changement il ya ici à droite et à
gauche
des hommes et des femmes qui ont fierté
de défendre leurs convictions et qui
savent que lorsque l'on veut tout
mélanger on ouvre la porte aux
extrémismes car chacun a besoin de se
situer dans la république et la
république a besoin non pas de confusion
mais d'un débat très clair où chacune et
chacun est ce qu'il est alors nous
voterons bien sûr cette motion pourquoi
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur pour
une raison à laquelle vous n'avez pas
encore apporté de réponse
à quoi sert ce texte il y à mes chers
collègues quelque chose d'étrange
nous parlons de ce texte depuis des
semaines si le but est de lutter contre
le salafisme contre le djihadisme
radical et violent
regardez les articles les uns après les
autres
et dites-moi ce qu'ils seront efficaces
à cet égard et vous verrez que l'on
accroît les contraintes de toutes choses
y compris pour les associations sans
pour autant aller dans le sens de
l'objectif affirmé il n'y a pas de
rapport entre l'objectif affirmé est les
différents articles du texte
c'est pourquoi nous considérons que ce
texte n'est pas bon qu'il faut prendre
les choses autrement et que nous
soutiendrons avec force la motion
présentée par notre groupe et par le
président patrick anr la parole est à
mme serrano
merci madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur présent
la commission des lois mesdames les
rapporteurs et monsieur rapporteur
fidèle à sa tradition le groupe rdse
votera contre cette motion
ça ne surprendra personne dans cet
hémicycle et cette fois aussi peut-être
encore plus que sur d'autres textes mais
ça a été rappelé parce que justement ce
projet de texte touche les fondements
mêmes de la république et nier le débat
sur ces sujets me semble extrêmement
grave
les français nous regarder nous
attendent sur ces sujets
la deuxième chose c'est que ça a été
rappelé là que la commission a beaucoup
les commissions ont beaucoup travaillé
sur le texte
un certain nombre d'amendements ont
d'ailleurs été déposées y compris par
notre groupe
il serait également inconcevable si le
texte est à parfaire comme j'ai pu
l'entendre de mon collègue soeur que
nous ne débattrons pas dans cet
hémicycle pour l'améliorer le cas
échéant bien évidemment par une série
d'amendements et puis enfin je pense que
ce texte mérite absolument que nous
n'ayons pas de postures caricaturales et
dogmatique
nous avons le temps de débat de longs
jours devant nous qui est impératif que
nous prenions de la hauteur de vue sur
ces sujets soyez assurés contout cote du
côté du rds eux nous manqueront pas de
prendre de la hauteur d'avoir un climat
apaisé de pouvoir discuter sereinement
dans le respect des différentes avis et
opinions politiques
je remercie mon ami at-elle merci madame
la présidente monsieur ministre mesdames
et monsieur le rapporteur mais sur
président mes chers collègues je crois
que dans ce pays il est temps de nommer
les choses de les dire et d'affirmer qu
ici aucun d'entre nous n'a choisi le
séparatisme ou l'entrisme mais chacun de
nous dans aujourd'hui nommer les choses
et répondent aux attentes des français
ce texte sans doute est incomplète dans
le volet de l'accompagnement social
mais je crois cher monsieur kaner vous
qui dites que ce texte vient toucher les
libertés il me semble que nous avons eu
il ya quelques années un débat sur la
volonté du gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez de revenir sur le système de
déclaration d'ouverture des écoles
privées pour un principe d'autorisation
et nous nous l'avons refusé au nom des
au nom des libertés
monsieur k nerfs je pense comme vous qui
si nous devons nous respecter
et justement parce que chacun d'entre
nous a le droit de s'exprimer et le
droit d'être audible je pense qu'il est
de notre devoir de lutter contre
l'entrisme et le séparatisme et oh non
je pense de toutes les victimes des
attentats au nom de tous ceux qui
souffrent d'une interdiction de parole
parce qu'aujourd'hui notre société les
colonisés par une pensée qui ne vise à
renverser la république je ne voterai
pas pour votre motion et sincèrement
monsieur kaner je pense que vous ne
pensez pas tout ce que vous dites
bien n'ayant plus de demandes
d'explications de vote
je vais consulter sénat sur cette motion
pressant de questions préalables dont je
le rappelle l'adoption entraînerait le
rejet du texte pas demandes de scrutins
publics qui est pour l'adoption qui et
contre qui s'abstient elle n'est pas
adoptée dans la discussion générale la
parole est maintenant monsieur claude
malhuret pour l'europe les indépendants
république et territoires
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues en 1937
jean ministre l'instruction publique du
front populaire
reddy's est la circulaire suivante je
vous prie de veiller à ce que soient
respectées les instructions interdisant
tout port d'un signe politique ou de
propagande confessionnelles
l'enseignement public et laïc aucune
forme de prosélytisme ne saurait être
admise dans les établissements une
simple circulaire pour faire respecter
la laïcité
aujourd'hui il faut une loi pour
s'opposer à la contestation des
principes républicains
que s'est il passé depuis janvier et
depuis clemenceau monsieur le président
caennais pour que nous en arrivions là
au début des années 80 sont nés de
mouvements de jeunes antiraciste france
plus le premier avait pour mots d'ordre
l'intégration républicaine
son slogan nous voulons le droit à la
ressemblance
le second sos racisme me proposer le
multiculturalisme abreuver de
subventions sur médiatisé par tous les
relais du jack lang isme triomphant n'y
fit une entrée fracassante dans le
paysage politico journalistique france
plus privé de tout moyen disparue
quarante ans plus tard et de nombreux
territoires perdus depuis par la
république la rengaine multiculturelle
et partout le victimisme est devenu la
base d'un discours qui aboutit sous
prétexte de tolérance a laissé chacun à
la discrétion de sa communauté et
surtout des plus intégristes en son sein
chaque jour montrent un peu plus le
communautarisme est dans une certaine
sous intelligencia universitaires les
discours délirant de l'indicé nisme de
la racisation ou du des colonialistes
les appels à la haine de soi viennent de
loin en 1961 alors que l'afrique noire
venait d'accéder à l'indépendance et que
les accords d'evian allait être signé
sartre écrivait à battre un européen
c'est faire d'une pierre deux coups
supprimer en même temps un oppresseur et
un opprimé reste un homme mort est un
homme libre
cinq ans plus tard c'est à normale sup
qui est apparu le spectacle effarant
au moment où le grand bond en avant
chinois faisait 50 millions de victimes
de centaines d'étudiants brandissant
frénétiquement le ridicule petit livre
rouge pendant qu'à pékin des millions de
chinois étaient forcés eux de le faire
sous peine de mort un saut instruits et
plus aucun sont ignorants des molières
aujourd'hui c'est des facultés de
sciences humaines que de pâles copieurs
de campus américains devenus fous nous
propose la version 21e siècle de
l'extrémisme déjanté après l'apologie du
stalinisme du trotskisme du maoïsme du
tiers-mondisme de l'altermondialisme du
collectionnisme voici venir l'éternel
retour du même sous la forme de
l'indigénisme et de l'islamo gauchisme
frédéric vidal a eu le mérite de nommer
l'éléphant que personne ne voulait voir
dans les locaux universitaires
mais quelle idée d'en proposer l'étude
au président du cnrs mathématicien mais
dont la compétence étant manifestement
bien au-delà de sa spécialité qui
écrivait dans la préface d'un livre
intitulé sexualité identité et corps
colonisés je cite la race devient la
nouvelle grille de lecture du monde sur
laquelle s'inscrit la grille du genre
dans une société non métis et le social
et le genre domine mais dans l'espace
interraciales le social s'efface
derrière leur acia le président du cnrs
c'est un peu comme si on confiait au
cowboy marlboro une enquête sur les
méfaits du tabac il a répondu à la
ministre que l'islamo gauchisme n'est
pas une réalité scientifique un peu
bizarre pour un concept forgé en 2004
par pierre andré taguieff directeur de
recherche au cnrs
pour le président du cnrs d'aujourd'hui
en revanche le racisme d'état le
privilège blanc la culture du viol la
fluidité identitaire semble être le nec
plus ultra des concepts scientifiques
on attend impatiemment les résultats de
l' enquête
est-ce que c'est islamo ou est-ce que
c'est gauchisme que l'éminent
scientifique a du mal à comprendre c'est
pourtant simple islamo c'est la
contraction d'islamisme gauchisme c'est
gauchisme islamo gauchistes c'est quand
le gauchisme ne fricote avec l'islamisme
the place to be
le 10 novembre 2019 c'était la marche
organisée par le comité contre
l'islamophobie en france
dissous depuis par le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre pour
cause d'islamisme à laquelle
participaient entre autres la france
insoumise
le npa benoît hamon et bien sûr l'unef
le syndicat qui n'aiment pas les blancs
au sujet de l'unef le professeur
mélenchon au sujet l'unef le professeur
m'élançant souvent dans l'erreur mais
jamais dans le doute vient d'écrire sur
son blog mardi dernier défendre l'unef
c'est lutter contre l'obscurantisme sans
commentaire cette manifestation
maigrelette fut pourtant un événement
considérable parce qu'elle a consacré la
fracture de deux gauches
d'un côté la gauche restait fidèle à ses
idéaux laïque et républicain inflexible
sur la mise à distance des assignations
identitaires de l'autre la gauche d
idiot utile de l'islamisme qui espère
enrôler les musulmans dans leur combat
intersectionnelle dont pourtant la
quasi-totalité des musulmans ne veut pas
on pourrait penser que je me réjouis de
cette fracture qui risque d'assurer à la
gauche de longues vacances mais je ne me
réjouis pas car avec la pression
croissante de l'islamisme et du
communautarisme l'unité nationale autour
de nos principes est crucial et dans
cette guerre des deux roses
j'ai peur que la dynamique et le battage
médiatique ne soit pas hélas
du côté de ceux qui défendent la laïcité
notant qu'avec cette question préalable
il semble avoir un petit coup de mou cet
après midi il est plus que temps de
s'attaquer à la montée les séparatistes
des fondamentalistes des projets anti
républicain c'est ce que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui et il n'y a pas de
raison de ne pas vous suivre
mais vous le savez messieurs les
ministres il y fera beaucoup plus qu'une
loi il y faudra une volonté c'est sur
elle-même que vous même votre
gouvernement et nous mêmes
parlementaires seront jugés
[Applaudissements]
madame benbassa je vais vous donner la
parole mais non voilà attendez un
instant
allez-y c'est bon
madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mesdames les rapporteurs
challes collègues
penchons nous sur l'exposé des motifs de
ce texte qui lit-on je cite un empirisme
communautariste insidieux mais puissant
gangrène lentement les fondements de
notre société
dans certains territoires c'est anti sme
est pour l'essentiel d'inspiration
islamiste
il y à peu madame frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
déclaré elle que l'islamo gauchisme
gangrené la société
la récurrence de ce thème médical n'est
pas anodine elle en dit long sur la
perception que certains ou en france de
l'islam en fait ils infecterait il pour
yves est il roseraie notre pays
au lieu de proposer des solutions pour
contre l islamisme radical en agissant
efficacement dans les territoires
touchés et en mettant la disposition de
cette action tous les moyens publics
nécessaires ce texte ne suggère que de
couper des membres gangréné sans aider
bien sûr à faire cesser dans l'esprit de
trop de nos concitoyens
la confusion entre islamisme radical et
islam élaboré après l'assassinât de
l'enseignant samuel pâtit ce texte dont
plus d'un tiers des articles vise à
renforcer les dispositifs de contrôle et
près d'un quart défini des peines
d'emprisonnement
facile il facilitera t-il la lutte
contre le mal qu'ils dénoncent
je crains que non et je suis la première
à le regretter
il tend surtout à renforcer le contrôle
social à restreindre les libertés et à
réprimer tous ceux qui ne se soumet pas
à l'ordre social que le pouvoir appelle
de ses voeux
en cette veille d'élection
présidentielle quand il espère ainsi
récolter des voix à la droite et
extrême droite ses répercussions seront
de surcroît importantes sur la vie des
autres
put l'archevêque de reims président de
la conférence des évêques de france
mme écrivait ceci dès janvier je cite
pour le dire synthétiquement la loi de
1905 est une loi de liberté un risque
avec ce projet de loi d transformer en
loi de contrôle de police et de
répression et il ajouté pour acquérir
des moyens nouveaux d'empêcher les
islamistes radicaux de mener à bien
leurs projets l'état multiplie les
contrôles et organise une nouvelle mise
sous tutelle des cultes je le rappelle
en passant que 7 h 20 qui parle et pas
la défenseur des droits le conseil
d'état juge lui même que le projet de
loi a alourdi les contraintes pesant sur
les associations cultuelles et modifie
l'équilibré
opéré en 1905 par le législateur ce
texte consacrant fait pour reprendre les
mots de françois clavero lee président
de la fédération protestante de france
je cite la dérive progressive
inquiétante de la compréhension de la
laïcité comme la grande idée libérale de
1905 vers une neutralisation religieuses
de notre société
la liberté associative sont globalement
menacées par ce têt les associations
même non religieuses sont inquiètes qui
voit l'octroi de subventions
conditionnée à la signature d'un contrat
d'engagement républicain aux contours
flous et à l'engagement de s'abstenir de
toute action préjudiciable à l'ordre
public
les associations écologistes pourrait
bien à terme en pâtir à leur tour car il
s'agit bien ici d'un texte de suspicion
généralisée ces cibles sont aujourd'hui
musulmane elle pourrait bien se
diversifier
l'avenir la laïcité socle de notre
cohésion nationale n'est plus ici qu'un
prétexte pour bâtir une république
autoritaire et inclusive dans un pays
sous état d'urgence sanitaire plus de
nom d'un an
monsieur d'al manar sol notre pacte
républicain en échappe répressive
l'article 18 sur le délit de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui par la
diffusion ou la transmission
d'informations sur un tir internet
remake de l'ancien article 24 de la
proposition de loi dont le nouveau kit
et pour un nouveau pacte sécurité
respectueux des libertés la teste bien
ce projet de loi aussi s'intitule
respect des principes de la république
respect respectueux voilà des mots qui
disent le contraire de ce que ces textes
sont vraiment liberticide
il est à regretter que les principes
expliqué de la république matelots niel
prennent le pas sur l'esprit de nos lois
la loi de 1905 comprise le combat contre
le fanatisme de certains groupes
islamistes et contre le terrorisme est
également notre combat mais pas à nos
pneus en optant obtint peu au tampon à
ce texte
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoire ne
pourra que voter contre ce texte je vous
remercie
la parole est à mme cet animal est
solide
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous ne pouvons
ouvrir ce débat sans nous accorder sur
un diagnostic partagé
le constat qui peut nous rassembler je
crois au delà de la terminologie qu'on
entend lui rattacher est celui d'une
force de fragmentation exercées par des
lois particulières sur la norme commune
il ne s'agit pas ici de défendre l'idée
que les lois particulières spirituel
notamment porterait en leur nature la
faction la séparation ou la sécession
il faut le redire ce projet de loi n'est
pas animé par une défiance envers le
fait religieux ni bien sûr vis-à-vis de
la démarche associatif non ils relèvent
d'un strict ambition de répondre aux
pressions de morcellement de la société
aux volontés d'une fraction extrémiste
de la population de quitter la
république et aux différentes
assignation et menaces mortifère
auxquels ces désagrégation conduisent ce
constat d'une dynamique de fragmentation
une fois posée doit nécessairement être
dépassée pour trouver les modalités de
réponse que le législateur peut lui
apporter
la tâche n'est pas aisée non seulement
la réponse ne saurait être simple et
univoque
mais elle n'est pas non plus réductible
à un véhicule législatif
il apparaît en tout cas que la voie
empruntée par le texte
dans la continuité des discours de
mulhouse et des mureaux du président de
la république ne remet pas en cause les
libertés dont il est question
je pense à la liberté d'association et
au principe de laïcité
clé de voûte en creux de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 et dont découle la liberté
de conscience et le libre exercice des
cultes ainsi que la neutralité de l'état
je pense également à des principes
matricielle tels que l'universalisme et
la conception élective de la nation
ce plébiscite de tous les jours pour
reprendre les mots éclairant d'ernest
renan l'inscription dans la continuité
de législateurs du début du 20e siècle
est soulignée par le conseil d'état nous
retrouvons cette continuité dans
plusieurs des dispositions du projet de
loi tel que la possibilité pour les
associations cultuelles de posséder et
d'administrer des immeubles de rapport
acquis à titre gratuit ou encore le
maintien de la liberté pour les cultes
de choisir les modalités de recrutement
de leurs officiant et de s'organiser
sous trois régimes différents cela
conformément à la loi de 1907 et en
procédant plus tôt par un mécanisme
d'incitation à rejoindre le régime de
l'association cultuelle d'autres
dispositions utiles du projet de loi ont
été conservés en commission je citerai
les mesures de transparence des
financements étrangers les articles
relatifs aux services publics avec
notamment le nouveau délit de
séparatisme le contrat d'engagement
républicain le renforcement de la lutte
contre la haine en ligne en cohérence
avec la dynamique européenne ou encore
la garantie de la dignité de la personne
humaine au travers de l'égalité femmes
hommes
je n'oublie pas bien sur la partie
relative à l'application des
dispositions à notre mère elle ne remet
pas en question et cela est heureux les
équilibres de ces territoires notamment
en guyane et à mayotte
le texte va évoluer sous l'effet de nos
débats et de nos initiatives
certains certains des amendements en
commission sont d'ailleurs venus
utilement consolider le texte ou prévoir
des assouplissements et j'en remercie
nos cours à porter je pense à
l'explicitation du champ d'application
des nouvelles obligations des
associations mixte plusieurs débats vont
animer notre hémicycle ont commencé dans
la question du champ d'application de
l'obligation de neutralité élus sujet du
port des signes religieux
sans préjuger de leur issue j'aimerais
toutefois rappelé que lors de l'examen
en commission plusieurs propositions en
ce sens ont été rejetés sur le fondement
d'une question mais
deux logiques simple mais indispensable
les dispositions sur lesquelles nous
nous prononçons permettent elles
d'atteindre le but que nous partageons
soit renforcer le respect par tous des
principes de notre république
à la lumière de cette question que nous
sommes collectivement poser en
commission l'absence de certaines
dispositions dans le texte procède je
crois non d'une omission mais bien au
contraire d'une délibération mûrement
réfléchie réfléchi pour reprendre ce
qu'annonçait aristide briand aussi j'ai
justement des signes religieux
j'espère que cette même exigence
méthodologique continuera de fonder nos
débats en séance
la parole est à la présidente nathalie
delattre pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen et pour
sept minutes
dans ma chronique
madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues beaucoup s'excuse d'être les
représentants de la démocratie beaucoup
s'excuse d'avoir raison beaucoup
s'excuse de respecter la loi et oublient
que sans la laïcité nous ne serions peut
être pas là à discuter tranquillement
c'est par ces mots que charb entamé son
discours de la remise de prix 2012 de la
laïcité décerné à notre ancien collègue
françoise laborde avant de poursuivre et
je le cite et j'ai moins peur des
extrémistes religieux que des laïcs qui
se taisent tonnerre d'applaudissements à
l'époque avant que le silence ne
reprenne sa place que la dénégation ou
le manque de courage ne fassent leurs
ravages car malgré le choc des attentats
de 2015 et la disparition de tandy dont
100 dont le dessinateur petits
arrangements et contournement ont repris
plus belle nous avons laissé s'exprimer
certes parfois en s'agitant mais jamais
assez fort ceux qui disent qu'après tout
ils l'ont bien cherché avec leurs
caricatures laisser dire ceux qui
affirment que l'engagement de nos
troupes militaires à l'étranger est une
provocation permanente laisser dénoncé
que nos lois sont finalement liberticide
et islamophobe
nous avons permis à ces bruits de fond
de parasiter depuis des années notre
société à ces attaques insidieuses et
pernicieuse de saper notre modèle laïc
la sentence tombe tel un couperet comme
moi vous avez découvert atterré les
conclusions de l'enquêté ifop pour la
licra résultats implacable nos jeunes
sont majoritairement favorables à
l'expression de la religiosité dans
l'espace public est hostile à la liberté
de la critique des religions
combien d'entre eux sont persuadés que
le blasphème est un crime en france
comment en sommes nous arrivés là
en consacrant la séparation des églises
et de l'état la loi du 9 décembre 2006
1905 à fonder notre ordre démocratique
forgé notre pacte républicain étayer
notre
devises à l' équilibre si fragile
pourtant la défendre aujourd'hui c'est
mettre sa vie en danger
nous l'avons subi avec de trop nombreux
crimes jusqu'à l'assassinât récent de
samuel pâtit professeurs des collèges
depuis ce drame le président de la
république a enfin amorcé la sortie de
ce long déni collectif politiques et
intellectuelles mais combien d'années se
sont écoulées avant de nommer l'ennemi
et l'identifier correctement
on nous a parlé de terrorisme de
communautarisme de radicalisme et
maintenant de séparatisme alors le
définir c'est le connaître le suivre et
lutter contre le coeur de son action
c'est la mission sénatoriale que nous
avons entreprise au sein de la
commission d' enquête sur le
développement de la radicalisation
islamiste et les moyens de la combattre
dès novembre 2019 revenus révélée comme
courageuse par nombre de journalistes au
côté de la rue rapporteur jacqueline
eustache brinio que je salue j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider ces travaux ils
ont à susciter une prise de conscience
rapide et clairvoyante notre objectif
partagé de démontrer l'ampleur du
phénomène de radicalisation au delà de
ses seuls manifestations violentes
nous avons mené plus de 60 heures
d'audition pour identifier
consciencieusement les dérives observées
sur notre territoire sans préjugés ni
tabou face à l'urgence nous avons
éclairé les secteurs devant faire
l'objet d'une vente d'une vigilance
particulière comme l'enseignement le
monde associatif et le monde sportif
dans lesquels la pression séparatistes
et forte des secteurs que nous
retrouvons dans ce texte
même si force est de constater que notre
école publique et nos établissements
d'enseignement supérieur ont été ici
quelque peu mis de côté je salue donc
les amendements portés par la commission
de la culture et de l'éducation pour
corriger cet écueil
il est regrettable toutefois monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation que vous ayez
des porter le débat sur l'instruction en
famille en stigmatisant les ef vous
avait choqué des milliers de parents qui
ont fait ce choix alors qu'ils ne
remettent pas en cause notre pacte
républicain les priver de cette liberté
c'est faire le jeu des islamistes et les
laisser remporté une victoire de plus
de vous rappeler que dès février 2019
j'ai déposé une proposition de loi et
vous le savez porter en amendement lors
de la loi pour une école de la confiance
aux fins de combattre les dérives que
vous dénoncez depuis peu ces amendements
visent et à l'amélioration à améliorer
l'identification via liên généraliser le
contrôle et le suivi de ces enfants sans
entraver la liberté de choix
d'instruction des parents ou les amis
est balayé aujourd'hui vous vous en
inspirer
nous avons perdu deux ans difficile
également de ne pas souligner l'absence
de mesures adressé au monde économique
qui fait pourtant face aux mêmes
problématiques
pour preuve le nombre de saisine de la
défenseur des droits qui témoignent de
la dégradation de l'ambiance dans nos
entreprises
je regrette aussi que nos élus locaux
n'est pas de bénéficier d'un arsenal de
mesures est dédié pour les accompagner
dans la gestion des relations avec les
représentants religieux et mettre fin à
toute forme d'un commandement local des
44 propositions contenues dans notre
rapport sénatorial publié le 7 juillet
dernier
de très nombreux dispositifs ont été
transposées dans votre projet doit
pourtant à aucun moment messieurs les
ministres à l'assemblée nationale et
j'ai lu l'ensemble des comptes rendus
vous n'avez échos évoqué notre
commission denquête je le déplore et
pourtant je ne peux ici que me réjouir
que nos travaux et puces incarné dans ce
texte
faute d'avoir été saluée renforcement de
la police des cultes alignement des
statuts légaux et fiscaux des lois de
1901 en 1905
prérequis d'une charte pour le versement
de subventions régime de déclaration d
apport de ressources étrangères etc etc
etc
je remercie également la commission des
lois d'avoir adopté des dispositifs
complémentaires défendue par la
commission denquête la dissolution
administrative d'associations placée
sous le contrôle du juge administratif
l'intégration du sexe ou de
l'orientation sexuelle dans le champ des
motifs de dissolution qui devrait
permettre de viser des structures
soutenant la lapidation des femmes ou la
mise à mort de personnes homosexuelles
le renforcement des sanctions en cas
d'atteinte à la liberté d'exercer un
culte comme un dispositif visant à mieux
protéger les conjoints
et les mineurs il convient d'aller plus
loin encore fervents défenseurs des
acquis de la loi 1905
le rds défendre à tout au long des
débats de nombreux amendements visant à
préserver cet héritage et faire de la
laïcité
notre meilleure arme contre le
radicalisme religieux pour que notre
pacte commun en sorte réaffirmé que
notre socle de valeurs n'en soit que
consolider et qu'enfin seules les lois
de la république préval je vous remercie
merci à paroles est maintenant à la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes et pour sept minutes
madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le texte
dont nous en entamant le débat
aujourd'hui répond-t-il aux attentes de
nos compatriotes
ce texte qui a pour objectif affiché de
lutter contre l'afflux ans de
l'islamisme politique dans notre société
et qu'il d'une telle urgence qu'il
faille en discuter en procédure
accélérée
plutôt que de traiter les besoins qu
exprime notre peuple face à la crise
sanitaire
alors oui bien sûr l'évolution du monde
et la dégradation profonde de notre
tissu social porte le développement d'un
fondamentalisme celui ci s'appuie en la
détournant sur la religion musulmane
pour imposer dans des pays des régions
du globe mais aussi dans des quartiers
une conception politique que je
qualifierais de fascisantes de la
société je vous le dis d'emblée ce n'est
pas par l'empilement de règles plus
répressives les unes que les autres que
vous répondrez à la déshérence d'une
population qui ne croient plus forcément
à la république car la république l'a
délaissée
l'urgence est d'ailleurs et ailleurs et
ailleurs aujourd'hui par dont l'urgence
c'est d'aider l'hôpital l'urgence c'est
de restaurer notre capacité à produire
des vaccins
l'urgence c'est d'agir pour le climat
l'urgence c'est de venir en aide aux 10
millions de pauvres dans notre pays ce
qui doit être éradiqué dans l'immédiat
c'est le malaise étudiants la détresse
sociale
la fin est certainement pas le fantasme
d'un islam au gauchisme concept que
votre gouvernement madame vidal en tête
et d'autres ici encore aujourd'hui livre
en pâture à l'extrême droite
l'urgence c'est les plans sociaux
toujours plus nombreux or pour le
gouvernement l'urgence des urgences
c'est légiférer sur le séparatisme
islamistes ainsi l'évolution des manuels
macro est patente de son discours de
2015 sur le terreau favorisant le
terrorisme au discours des mureaux qu'il
y ait action esprit répressive et action
sociale
nous avons découvert le 9 décembre
dernier un texte qui devait peu de jours
avant conforter les principes
républicains pour finalement aboutir à
un texte coercitif visant à assurer le
respect des principes de la république
dont on ne sait pas qu'il est définie
quel est leur chant lattes la notion de
séparatisme ne figure plus dans
l'intitulé du projet doit et pour cause
le grand test
le grand texte séparatisme en matière de
religion c'est celui de 1905 qui assure
la séparation de l'église et de l'état
qui actent à l'entrée de notre pays dans
une république laïque
après une longue histoire le mou
séparatisme se perd finalement dans les
contradictions fondamentales de votre
action vous ne pouvez pas de sur quoi
portait ce concept alors que le
séparatisme fondamentale de notre
société
c'est aujourd'hui solide et celui des
riches avec les pauvres
notre pays subit de plein fouet un
séparatisme multiples séparatisme
scolaire séparatisme universitaire 30%
des enfants de classes défavorisées
atteignez l'ena le mshc en 1950
aujourd'hui c'est 9% séparatisme
territoriale renforcée par la mise à mal
de l'unicité du service
publique dans notre pays avec votre
texte le discours d' emmanuel macron aux
mureaux en octobre dernier apparaît bien
loin
le président de la république comme à
son habitude avait porté le en même
temps il faut réprimer le séparatisme
islamique mais il faut aussi restaurer
la république sur tous les territoires
je le cite nous avons nous-mêmes
construit notre propre séparatisme c'est
celui de nos quartiers si la gated et
autorisation de notre république
nous avons construit une concentration
de misère nous avons ainsi créé des
quartiers où la promesse de la
république n'a plus été tenus fin de
citation monsieur mâcon à jeter aux
orties l'habillage social de son propos
pour ne conserver que l'objectif
répressif et coercitif nous ne trouvons
donc face à un texte qui se bécotent qui
se veut comme l'héritage des auteurs de
la loi de 1905 alors que ce texte était
fondamentalement une loi de liberté dans
son article premier a garanti la liberté
de conscience et la liberté des cultes
et dans son article de l affirme la
république ne reconnaît ne salarie ni ne
subventionne aucun culte
c'est la séparation de l'église et de
l'état à l'opposé d'une démarche content
concordataire qui subsistent encore en
alsace moselle avec les récentes
conséquences que nous connaissons et
dans quelques autres départements et
territoires
votre texte prend à contre-pied la loi
de 1905
car il renforce le lien entre les
religions et l'état il contredit
l'esprit de 1905 il tend à un nouveau
concordat
ce projet de loi s'inscrit par contre
pleinement dans un continuum sécuritaire
de la loi sécurité globale comment ne
pas signaler ici l'article 18 à petit
miroir de l'article 24 du texte
précédemment cités à la réforme de
l'ordonnancé mineurs en passant par la
perpétration des états d'exception
depuis 2015
car votre texte desbordes de la question
religieuse en instaurant un contrat
d'engagement républicains là aussi qui
le définit qui le valide vous placer
l'ensemble des associations sous tutelle
vous rétablissez le lien entre l'état et
les religions
et vous savez bien que l'ensemble des
associations cultuelles critique cette
évolution
vous remettez en cause la liberté
d'association au placement au coeur d'un
contrat d'engagement républicain la
question du respect de l'ordre public
regardons alors le contrôle du
financement des associations culturelles
monsieur patrick weil affirmé fort
justement je cite la loi prévoit déjà
depuis 1905 pour les associations
culturelles le contrôle de
l'administration fiscale et de
l'inspection générale des finances
les contrôles ont ils été faits quand
ils auront lieu où il aurait dû l'être
c'est la maladie française on fait des
lois pour camoufler l'absence d'actions
dans le cadre des lois précédentes fin
de citation
regardons la question des exemptions de
pratiques sportifs sportingbet
ce n'est pas votre texte qui règle la
faiblesse de la médecine scolaire qui
par son retour dans chaque établissement
pourrait permettre de régler dans le
dialogue et le suivi réel ces situations
et bien d'autres je ne supporte pas la
stigmatisation dont sont victimes les
millions de musulmans ou celles et ceux
que l'on considère comme tel qui habite
dans notre pays dont la très grande
majorité sont nos compatriotes je ne
supporte pas que pour une minorité
agissante qu'il faut combattre et les
communistes n'ont jamais ils n'ont
jamais failli à ce combat est long trop
souvent payé de leur vie dans des pays
où la guerre civile fait rage que ce
soit donc une part significative de
notre peuple qui soit montré du doigt ma
colère monsieur le ministre est d'autant
plus vive que ces femmes premières
victimes de tous les obscurantismes et
ses hommes sont souvent confrontés à de
grandes difficultés sociales
je ne peux accepter ce que vous avez
écrit dans votre livre sur nice à propos
de ceux qui s'inquiéteraient d'une
xénophobie d'état stigmatiser ce je vous
cite qui mêlent leurs voix et leurs
protestations aux cris aux actes de ceux
qui attaquent la france et qui serait je
vous cite encore le col est complice des
islamistes le jeu est dangereux monsieur
le ministre
et c'est emmanuel macron les droits
incluront madame la présidente qui
favorise front national le pen n'a pas
besoin de trades paraît puisque le
travail
effects jamais si bien
la parole est à madame marie pierre de
la gontrie pour six minutes pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues le 2 octobre dernier
le président de la république a tenu un
discours important sur la lutte contre
le séparatisme
le 16 octobre 14 jours plus tard samuel
pâtit était assassiné par un terroriste
islamiste dans les rues près de son
collège
ces circonstances nous oblige et ce
n'est pas monsieur grosperrin faire une
référence
béate à un discours du président de la
république que de considérer que le jour
où le chef de l'état s'exprime sur un
sujet aussi grave
il est important de l'entendre de le
lire et ensuite de regarder quelles sont
les conséquences que nous pouvons en
tirer c'est pour cela que je vous le dis
je trouve inacceptable que vous ayez
évoqué le fait que en réponse au
président caennais nous pourrions être
complaisant avec l'islamisme radical
comment peut-on dire ça alors que notre
pays
ma ville les français ont connu lors du
quinquennat précédent
les attentats contre charlie puis contre
le bataclan et que certains d'entre nous
ont perdu des proches et des membres de
leur famille donc je pense que vous avez
été emportés sans doute par la volonté
d'être très radical dans votre position
mais de la même manière que plusieurs de
nos collègues l'ont dit ensuite ce débat
difficile parce que nous ne partageons
pas forcément la même conception mais
nous devons garder une certaine hauteur
une certaine maîtrise et c'est à cela
comme d'autres que je souhaiterais
vous appelez car les circonstances que
je rappelais de l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit nous oblige pouvait laisser
l'oratrice poursuivre s'ils vous pour la
gauche le débat va être long il va durer
plusieurs jours économisant nous
j'essaye monsieur pieds noirs d'être à
la hauteur je vous rassure tout comme
vous pour la gauche
la république doit être la république
jusqu'au bout pour reprendre la formule
de jaurès l'ordre républicain à côté la
promesse républicaine de l'autre notre
groupe est fondamentalement attachés au
respect des principes de la république à
leur protection et nous saluons les
femmes et les hommes qui la servent
fonctionnaires militaires enseignants
comme personnel soignant tous ceux qui
ont choisi de servir l'intérêt général
nous sommes attachés à la laïcité oui
nous sommes fidèles à l'héritage de
jaurès de briand ou de ferdinand puisse
du son à cette liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire et nous sommes attachés à
la dignité humaine contre toutes les
pratiques indignes en particulier contre
les femmes
certains l'ont rappelé séparer le combat
laïque du combat social c'est ce que
vous voyez au risque de perdre les deux
car la république doit être laïque selon
la fameuse formule de jaurès parce
qu'elle aura su être social d'ailleurs
lors de son discours des mureaux
emmanuel macron rappelait la république
c'est à la fin un ordre une promesse
mais il évoquait un devoir d'espoir le
besoin de faire aimer la république pour
que chacun y trouve sa place
or cette deuxième partie du discours du
président de la république a disparu car
pas un mot sur la mixité sociale sur la
discrimination en matière d'emploi ou de
logement l'accès aux services publics
l'égalité des chances or la république
c'est une promesse
la promesse d'être intégrée de
participer c'est la promesse
républicaine d'égalité d'émancipation
nous élus locaux le savons bien
nous savons que si nous n'abordons pas
ses sujets le texte est totalement
déséquilibré or dans ce texte
notre république est donc réduite à des
règles d interdiction des motifs d'ordre
public et nous ne retrouvons pas le
pendant lé droit l'égalité la solidarité
et les principes de la république c'est
ça aussi il ya de toute évidence l'ordre
qui était appelée de ses voeux par
prisons de la république pour les
associations les cultes l'éducation les
fédérations sportives le service public
ce texte prévoit obligations contrôle
sanction ça a été rappelée déjà
plusieurs fois c'est étrange quand on
présente ce texte comme un texte de
liberté mais ce texte aussi s'avérer
dangereux pour nos libertés notamment
lorsqu'on regarde l'article 18 qui est
l'article jumeaux de ce qu'on appelle un
faux jumeaux en l'occurrence de
l'article 24 du texte sécurité globale
et qui va nous amener
je le dis au ministre de l'intérieur a
créé une concurrence juridique qui va
rendre très complexe la poursuite des
infractions et je pense que le
gouvernement devrait y veiller ce texte
est aussi un texte de défiance envers
les croyants les membres d'associations
l'école et au final tous les citoyens
comme si chacun d'eux venait suspect et
comme si chacun allait se radicaliser
sur quelques points nous partageons les
propositions de ce projet de loi par
exemple dans les dispositions permettant
une meilleure protection des agents du
service public où les mesures visant à
améliorer l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
l'interdiction des certificat de
virginité la lutte contre les mariages
forcés ou la polygamie des combats que
nous partageons évidemment et sur
lesquels mes collègues jacques bernard
magner et jean pierre sueur reviendront
tout à l'heure mais comme vous l'aurez
compris nous nous satisfaisons pas de
l'ensemble de ce projet en quoi
pourra-t-il enrayer la fuite de la
société de certains
le repli sur soi l'antre soit pour nous
vivre mieux ensemble
avec cette loi les français seront ils
mieux protégés allons-nous resterait
cette république qui permet et
promettant ces sujets auraient dû être
approchée comme le disait montesquieu
d'une main tremblante 40 pouces en
conséquence modifier les textes
fondateurs comme la loi de 1905 ni
légiférer sur des sujets aussi
fondamentaux
il est incontestable que lors de la
rédaction de ce texte la main du
gouvernement n'a pas tremblé
suffisamment je pense qu'elle l'aurait
dû aujourd'hui au sénat nous devons
appréhender ce texte comme ils auraient
dû être rédigé un texte d'ordre sans
doute mais aussi un texte de promesses
or ce n'est pas le cas et vous l'avez
compris nous n'approuvons pas ce texte
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
stéphane ravier pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président messieurs madame
la présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues dans 20 ans et sur la france
sera une république islamique
tel était le voeu le projet exprimé en
1986 dans le quotidien de paris par un
certain hussein moussawi un des chefs du
hezbollah libanais si 35 ans plus tard
ce projet n'est pas achevée force est de
constater qu'il est en cours de
réalisation
car ce ne sont pas moins que 250
quartiers en france qui sont aujourd'hui
tenues par les islamistes
et ces quartiers ne se situe pas
seulement dans le secteur nord de
marseille dans la banlieue lyonnaise ou
parisienne mais aussi un hamas à lunel à
oyonnax à nogent le rotrou ou encore à
maubeuge où le clair de lune a été
remplacé par le croisant le croissant de
lune islamique et ce n'est plus mais
alors plus du tout la même chanson et
pendant ce temps votre gouvernement
messieurs les ministres n'a toujours pas
le courage de nommer le mal une
frilosité qui vous conduit à des
contorsionnistes semantic législatif qui
ne sont pas sans conséquence sur les
libertés publiques en général des autres
religions en particulier faute de nommer
l'ennemi votre texte est liberticide
pour ceux qui respectent la loi est
largement insuffisant pour ceux qui la
piétinent et ces dames politique et ses
soutiens voilà l'ennemi voilà la cible
or on ne retrouve pas dans votre texte
une seule fois les termes charia jihad
islamique mosquée voile ni même tabou
parmi les tabous immigration et puisque
les choses doivent être dites
ce n'est pas tant les valeurs de la
république que les islamistes veulent
abattre c'est la france la france des
terroirs et des clochers la france
enraciner la france française
aujourd'hui en france 57 % des jeunes
musulmans préfèrent l'application de la
charia la loi islamique aux lois de la
république
plus d'un jeune musulman de france sur
deux donc ne se reconnaît pas dans le
modèle qui l'a vu naître
ils n'ont que faire de votre vivre
ensemble ils ne sont même plus dans la
séparation mais dans une volonté de
conquête en exigeant que nous vivions
comme eux les métastases islamistes se
sont répandues dans tout le corps
national
elles ont contaminé nos écoles nos
universités nos médias la culture le
sport et mai
et maintenant hémicycle et la majorité
écrasante de les terroristes sont des
étrangers ou des produits issus de
l'immigration car je le répète il
n'aurait de cesse de le répéter
l'islamisme n'est pas une cause mais une
conséquence une conséquence de
l'immigration massive
après avoir nommé le mal est identifié
ses origines sachons nous attaquer à ces
soutiens de l'intérieur le poisson y
compris politiques pourrit toujours par
la tête et des islamistes savent pouvoir
compter tant sur ce l'islamo gauchisme
que sur l'islam ou droitisme le premier
par idéologie anti française et le
second par électoralisme qui conduit
nombre d'élus locaux a collaboré avec
l'ennemi obtenir 51 % des voix comme
d'autre prenez trente deniers fait subir
à la france et aux français à notre
civilisation européenne un véritable
calvaire
le texte du gouvernement est une
occasion ratée de vacciner un peu notre
pays contre la pandémie islamistes je
vous engage dès lors mes chers collègues
à soutenir les initiatives visant à lui
donner toute la force et la
détermination dont il a besoin
l'avenir n'est jamais irrévocable il
sera ce que nous aurons décidé mais dans
tous les cas soyez assurés qui vous
jugera la parole est maintenant monsieur
notre belle mais pour le groupe union
centriste et pour sept minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mais d'amener
rapporteur chers collègues
ce projet de loi touche au principe
constitutionnel de laïcité et à celui de
la liberté
il pose en filigrane une question
centrale face à la transformation de nos
sociétés où nous perdons de vue ce qui
nous est commun au profit des droits
individuels
comment concilier la liberté du citoyen
et la liberté de l'individu
il existe un cadre juridique il est
parfois paradoxales l'article 1er de
notre constitution énonce que la
république laïque respecte toutes les
croyances
la laïcité est le fruit d'un long débat
ils résultent
elle résulte d'un compromis la loi de
1905 vécu douloureusement s'inscrit dans
un contexte de loi antérieure anti
religieuse elle s'est voulue une loi d'
équilibre en tenant compte de la réalité
de la société française à cette époque
un écart parfois considérables existent
entre le principe voulu et la réalité la
laïcité telle qu'elle s'est construite
est une réalité historique défini en
fonction des situations et des problèmes
rencontrés
il en est ainsi aujourd'hui avec une
religion qui en france métropolitaine
n'existait pas au début du siècle
dernier les acteurs du débat
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas les mêmes
leurs références non plus de même la
notion de laïcité peut ne pas recouvrir
la même signification selon les
générations
la méthode qui a présidé au début du
siècle et celle de l'apaisement pour la
liberté dans la diversité plaidé
clemenceau et la république cité des
consciences autonome pour le philosophe
renouvier votre projet de loi monsieur
le ministre s'efforce à l' équilibre
il le revendique l'islamisme politique
et le salafisme se nourrissent de
l'inorganisation de l'islam en france
c'est une part importante du sujet mais
la loi ne peut contraindre une religion
à s'organiser
d'un côté nous faut lutter contre la
propagation du séparatisme contre la
haine en ligne pour la protection des
services publics pour l'incitation des
cultes intégré statut de la loi 1905
connaître leurs financements pour
s'assurer de toute absence d' ingérence
étrangère
tout cela sans attenter à la liberté de
culte à la liberté d'expression à la
liberté de religion à la liberté
d'association et avec pour seul outil
la loi est égale pour tous l'ordre
public les règles minimales de vie en
société l'intérêt public local l'intérêt
vital de la nation
la commission a je crois permis d'aller
plus loin dans l'équilibré jusqu'à ce
matin et j'espère que cela sera constant
je rejoins un nouveau clemenceau qui
déclaré s'il pouvait y avoir un conflit
entre la république et la liberté c'est
la république qui aurait tort concernant
la neutralité des services publics
notre commission s'est montrée cohérente
en étendant aux salariés participant à
une mission de service public les mêmes
obligations que les agents et a refusé
leur extension aux élus au delà de leurs
fonctions d'agent de l'état
elle a amélioré le contrat d'engagement
républicain en transférant au préfet
l'obligation d'informer les organismes
qui concourent au financement d'une
association qui a fait l'objet d'un
retrait d'une subvention alors que les
députés avaient confié cette obligation
aux élus locaux
notre commission a introduit le juge
judiciaire dans la procédure de
suspension des fonds de dotation par
l'autorité administrative
avec loïc hervé particulièrement
j'aurais souhaité qu'il en soit de même
dans le cadre de la procédure
d'astreinte prévu à l'article 30
concernant le respect des droits des
personnes et l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
nous soutenons les articles qui
interdisent la polygamie qui prive et
pénalise la réalisation par des
professionnels de la santé de certificat
de virginité
de même nous sommes favorables au
dispositif de lutte contre l'excision
la commission a fait oeuvre utile
concernant les mariages forcés ou vicié
en prévoyant que l'officiel et à des
civils puissent consulter une base de
données nationale recensant l'ensemble
des décisions d'opposition et de sursis
des mariages la commission culture a
rétabli la liberté de l'instruction en
famille et organiser son meilleur
contrôle la liberté et le contrôle
plutôt que l'interdiction est
l'exception autorisé la commission à
améliorer l' équilibre celle des lois
entre liberté de culte est nécessaire
contrôle notamment des financements sans
pénaliser les associations
qui sont respectueuses des lois de la
république nous pouvons apaisé améliorer
l' équilibre encore et rendre davantage
attractif le cadre de la loi de 1905 par
exemple pour rendre davantage
d'autonomie
les associations cultuelles dépourvu
financement étranger
la commission a supprimé le plafond de
30 3% que devait représenter les
ressources tirées d'un immeuble acquis à
titre gratuit
nous sommes nombreux à vouloir que les
associations puissent également vivre de
ressources issues des immeubles acquis à
titre onéreux comme le soulignait aussi
le président bah il est incompréhensible
aujourd'hui en l'absence de toute
puissance immobilière possible que les
associations cultuelles puisse placer
leurs trésoreries dans un portefeuille
d'actions mais n'est pas la possibilité
d'acheter un immeuble de même toujours
dans un souci d'autonomie financière des
associations cultuelles avec mes
collègues nous avons déposé un
amendement qui vise à augmenter le
plafond des dons en liquide pour
l'aligner sur celui prévu par le décret
2015 concernant le paiement en espèces
entre particuliers et professionnels
enfin s'agissant des dispositions
relatives à la police des cultes si la
commission a approuvé le nouveau
dispositif de fermeture administrative
des lieux de culte en cas de provocation
à la haine ou à la violence
elle a limité à trois mois la durée de
cette fermeture ce dispositif est apparu
à certains disproportionnée car elle ne
dispose pas de garanties telles que le
contrôle par le parlement sous forme de
rapports réguliers présenté au sénat et
à l'assemblée
dès lors ce dispositif sans garantie par
et attentatoire aux libertés publiques
et nous souhaitons le limiter dans le
temps
c'est l'objet de l'amendement 584 pour
conclure je citerai locke dans sa lettre
sur la tolérance en 1686 il écrivait il
est d'une nécessité absolue de
distinguer avec tout l'exactitude
possible ceux qui regardent le
gouvernement civil de ce qui appartient
à la religion et de marquer les justes
bornes qui sépare les droits de l'ain et
ceux de l'autre sans cela il n'y aurait
jamais de fin aux disputes qui
s'élèveront entre ceux qui s'intéressent
ou qui prétendent s'intéresser d'un côté
au salut des âmes et de l'autre aux
biens de l'état ap zon équilibre on
encore
mesdames les rapporteurs je salue votre
travail et celui qu'il vous faut encore
réalisé pendant les débats à venir
apaisant équilibrons encore sans
empêcher évidemment que la cible soit
bien atteinte
je vous remercie chers collègues de
votre attention merci la parole est
maintenant au président bruno retailleau
pour re neuf minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs le rapporteur sert collègues
ce texte je pense aurait pu porter le
nom de ce mail pâtit il aurait pu porter
aussi le nom d'arnaud beltrame disent
que le hasard du calendrier veut que ça
fait presque jour pour jour trois ans
que nous avons rendu cet hommage aux
invalides à arnaud beltrame le match au
courage et nous étions nombreux parmi
nous dans cette cour minérale des
invalides nous étions nombreux à
formuler ce voeu que son courage que ce
courage français soit aussi notre
courage le courage de la france est en
réalité la seule question que nous ayons
à examiner pour jauger de ce texte de
ces mesures
c est ce que le courage est au coeur de
ce texte parce que nous savons
la situation est gravissime tous les
sondages toutes les études nous démontre
aurons nous le courage de la difficulté
de la situation
j'aurais monsieur le ministre aimé
répondre oui je dois à la vérité de
penser je voudrais le montrer rapidement
que bien sûr qu'il ya des mesures utiles
et que nous allons voter et que le vrai
courage n'est pas au coeur de ce texte
parce que le courage pour moi cet aller
au bout des choses aller au fond des
choses
vous n'allez pas au bout des choses
quand vous arrêter sur la neutralité sur
la laïcité à mi chemin vous n'osez pas
parler du voile dans notre histoire et
centre des gouvernements ont fait un
autre choix et le temps leur a donné
raison qui m'est cher collègue qui
aujourd'hui s'opposent à la loi de 2004
à la loi de 2010 très peu de gens si
précisément les islamistes et on n'en
parle pas vous n'allez pas au bout des
choses et vous n'allez pas non plus au
fond des choses
en réalité de séparatisme islamiste ne
vient pas de nulle part
il a été encouragé par le
communautarisme et le communautarisme a
été aussi encouragés par une immigration
massive donc on a perdu le contrôle par
la panne de l'intégration la panne de
l'intégration mais aussi notre
renoncement devant la simulation mais
l'assimilation et assimilés qu'est ce
que c'est que l' inverse de ses parts et
bien sûr que la simulation
c'était c'est une contrainte pour les
nouveaux venus
mais c'est surtout pour la citoyenneté
pour la république française une
promesse la promesse donnée à chacun
quelle que soit la couleur de sa peau
quelle que soit sa confession de devenir
pleinement français
c'est ça aussi la simulation j'ai vu il
ya quelques jours monsieur le ministre
dans un quotidien que vous auriez aimé
que ce texte portable plus ambitieux et
vous avez cité l'immigration je dis
chiche
nous sommes prêts à vos côtés à vous
aider à effacer ce regret si vraiment il
y en a d'où vient ce manque d'ambition
finalement il vient du en même temps il
vient du en même temps parce que le en
même temps c'est toujours faire un petit
peu mais pas trop
c'est semblé faire mais souvent faire
semblant n'est ce pas le prison la
république qui en avril 2018 indiqué
parlant du voile qu'il était contraire à
la civilité notre société très bien pour
les mots mais on attend les actes
c'est peut-être aussi ses hésitations
c'est peut-être aussi cette peur d'être
traiter d'islamophobe et je sais que
certains usent souvent de cette
rhétorique là qu'il faut dénoncer bien
entendu mais du coup ce texte la bascule
pour éviter cette peur vers la
contrainte de ceux qui ne font pas peur
des familles qui honnêtement élèvent
leurs enfants éduquent leurs enfants
instruits leurs enfants à leur domicile
vis-à-vis d'autres q je ne pense pas que
ce texte soit un régime et un texte de
liberté bien entendu je pense qu'il ya
et il fait des dommages collatéraux des
dommages collatéraux à la laïcité
heureusement notre commission des lois
réparera rééquilibrera un certain nombre
de points pour que les cultes qui ne
pose aucun problème à la république
n'endosse pas en réalité tous ces
dommages collatéraux
quelle drôle d'idée vis-à-vis de la
laïcité quelle drôle d'idée qui était
celle du président de la république de
confier au cfcm
l'idée de créer un institut pour des
imams français je pense que c'est
contraire avec la définition que je me
fais de la laïcité quand on sait que le
cfcm
on l'a vu depuis mais on le savait
depuis longtemps en réalité est tiraillé
entre un islam consulaires sujet aux
influences étrangères ou à l'islam 0
salafiste radical politisé et on voulait
leur confier la formation des imams
je pense que ça n'est pas raisonnable
dommages collatéraux aussi à la liberté
de l'instruction cette vieille air
liberté républicaine consacrée par jules
ferry mais aussi par clémenceau qui ce
que chaque incident clemenceau le
vendéen je voudrais apporter ma
contribution
ici en 1903 le 27 novembre
clemenceau c'est parce que je suis
contre le roi contre l'empereur contre
le pape que je suis contre l'état
omnipotent souverain et souverain maître
de l'humanité parce qu'il choisissait
bien sûr
serrano d'amener la liberté et votre
gouvernement alors que depuis 1882
aucune république aucun gouvernement n'a
jamais touché à cette liberté de
l'instruction qui est une des trois
voies de la liberté de l'enseignement
et bien malheureusement sans aucune
preuve sans aucune raison vous allez la
mettre à mal je pense que la situation
est grave dans laquelle nous sommes
elle exige de mieux cibler le texte
malheureusement ni d'identification
pleut man notre adversaire notre et demi
cet adversaire vous le savez il a un nom
c'est l'islam politique
il a bien entendu aussi la loi sa loi la
charia et tout les principes et valeurs
contraires la thermique
nous souhaitons que en matière de droit
des étrangers
nous ne puissions pas prolongée des
cartes de séjour dès lors que quelqu'un
professe des principes qui soit l'
inverse des principes républicains
un nom une loi évidemment un étendard le
voile nous y reviendrons notamment sur
les sorties scolaires
avec l'amendement de max brisson et puis
évidemment il a des complices
je parlais et des idiots utiles et je
veux parler de cette grande
international de l'islamo gauchisme du
des colonialismes et d'autres sottise
qui sont des styles sans doute mais qui
sont des sottises extrêmement
dangereuses et l'unef ici en france et
d'une est une des ces cires kursaal
puisque lui 9 racisées elle veut
racisées les réunions c'est à dire que
désormais c'est la race qui devient un
critère ça celle inverse de la
république française
mes chers amis et nous devons lutter
puisque vous voulez lutter monsieur le
ministre contre séparatiste où les
séparatistes et bien fait en sorte que
le gouvernement sur soi ve aux quatre
chats sont 1000 euros de subventions
données annuellement à une oeuvre j'ai
vu que la semaine dernière le
gouvernement avait nommé un représentant
de l'unef
au 16e c'est totalement con tradicteur
nous sommes encore dans le en même temps
et encore une fois je pense que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une situation aussi
grave avec un ennemi aussi radicale
on ne peut pas faire dans la demi mesure
on ne peut pas faire dans le en même
temps et puis enfin cet ennemi il a une
histoire une mémoire
un récit qui voudraient ramener nos
compatriotes français musulmans eux à
l'islam des origines hausse à l'afld
qu'elle ressine ou républicains nous
français pouvons nous opposer au récit
justement des islamistes parce que dans
ce combat
non seulement il va falloir reconquérir
les territoires perdus par la république
de dans la république mais aussi
reconquérir les esprits et les coeurs
perdus par la république et on n'y
parviendra pas en creusant le vide de la
france en désignant la france comme une
éternelle coupable comme un anti modèle
compte un contre exemple comment
voulez-vous agrégé ces jeunes
générations à la france si vous
présentez la france comme peu estimable
comme toujours coupables coupables du
pire des crimes le crime contre
l'humanité bien entendu eh bien je crois
que c'est grâce à l'épaisseur de notre
culture à la profondeur de notre
civilisation
et puis aussi à la hauteur de notre
message à la fois singulier et universel
que nous parviendrons à agréger
notamment ses plus jeunes générations
issues de l'immigration à notre destin
national réaffirmer les principes dans
république guy férez mais la france
c'est plus difficile mais c'est
fondamental
[Applaudissements]
bien la parole est maintenant madame
nadège avait pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant et pour 3
minutes
monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente mesdames les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission mais chers collègues
cela a été rappelé ce texte concrétise
le programme de lutte contre le sait les
séparatismes dessiné par le président de
la république lors de son discours aux
mureaux ils portent des avancées
importantes nécessaires et attendues en
introduction au débat
nous voudrions faire part de notre
étonnement sur la motion déposée qui
prétend qu'il y aurait pas lieu de
délibérer à surprises pourtant certaines
prises de positions de ces derniers
jours nous rappellent pourtant qu'il y a
un urgent besoin de débat en la matière
et de débats auxquels toutes les
citoyennes et tous les citoyens peuvent
participer dans une république
indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale
je consacrerai montcourt propos champ
éducatif
nous voterons l'article 1 bis qui inclut
à la formation des enseignants et des
personnels de l'éducation à la formation
aux principes de laïcité
de même que nous nous voterons le
renforcement des contrôles sur les
établissements d'enseignement privés
hors contrat
le renforcement des sanctions à
l'encontre des chefs d'établissements
d'enseignement privé hors contrat mais
connaissant des mises en demeure
nous voterons également la signature
d'une charte des valeurs et principes
républicains
nous proposerons en outre de rétablir
l'article 21 et j'y reviendrai lors de
nos échanges nous voterons enfin pour
plus de mixité sociale dans les écoles
de même que la compensation lorsque
celle ci est absente en continuité des
prises de position que mon groupe a eu
sur ce sujet lors des débats de l'école
de la confiance
oui l'autorité déconcentré doit
travailler avec les établissements
publics et privés sous contrat
d'un même bassin de vie et les
collectivités territoriales concernées
pour améliorer la mixité sociale au sein
de ces établissements
oui la commission de concertation
chargée d'examiner les contrats
d'association doit veiller au
développement de la mixité sociale des
publics scolarisés au sein des
établissements prix
et sous contrat oui enfin aux transferts
aux conseils départementaux des données
sociales anonymisées des élèves relevant
des établissements publics et privés de
la circonscription faisons toutefois
attention sur ces bandes pas participer
à ce que j'appellerais un effet mikado
où nous parlerions beaucoup pour
finalement décevoir trop d'attentes ont
été déçus ces trente dernières années
alors que nous tirons continûment la
sonnette d'alarmé sur les effets
délétères des inégalités sociales en
france et le manque de mixité dans les
grandes zones urbaines et rurales en
particulier dans nos écoles se sont
preuve d'un grand volontarisme mais
aussi d'humilité
au regard de l'état des lieux qui était
celui dressé au début du quinquennat
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant madame nathalie goulet pour
le groupe union centriste et pour six
minutes
la présidente monsieur minier s'est
nommé rapporteur du cher collègue arrivé
11e dans un débat comme ça monsieur le
ministre je vais quand même vous
expliquez que ici nous avons quelques
ancienneté en 2014 j'avais demandé une
commission dans lequel sur les réseaux
djihadistes avec mon collègue andré
reichardt puis une mission d'information
sur l'islam qui est quand même le
rapport le plus sérieux et le plus
complet qui a été fait sur la situation
de l'islam en france depuis et moi
monsieur le ministre je trouve que des
dispositions sont tout à fait
excellentes dans ce texte
toutes les mesures qui concerne le
contrôle financier des associations
l'alignement des statuts 1901 en 1905
je voudrais rappeler que dans cet
hémicycle nous avions voté à plusieurs
reprises cette disposition notamment en
2016 c'était une disposition qui avait
également été votée à l'assemblée
nationale et que c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui a considéré que
c'est peut-être un cavalier qu'il a fait
sauter de la loi égalité citoyenneté
cette disposition avait été reprise en
2017 2018 2019
donc vous voyez qu on avait eu quelques
constance et puis elle arrive dans votre
texte et monsieur ministre moi je n'ai
qu'à me féliciter de même que le
renforcement de trac fin me semble une
excellente opération j'ajoute que est la
suite d'un amendement brillant la
commission a adopté le contrôle des
cagnottes en ligne qui était également
demandé par tracts fin et retoqué
plusieurs fois dans cet hémicycle
jusqu'à ce que notre commission
l'adoptent ce qui est aussi une bonne
chose
alors monsieur le ministre moi ce que je
voudrais vous poser comme question c'est
combien de divisions
parce que quels moyens allez vous mettre
en place pour effectuer des contrôles
un ancien ministre de l'économie et des
finances et plusieurs avant lui donc
cessé de réduire les effectifs des
missions de contrôle
on m'a soufflé dans l'oreillette que les
dispositions de l'article 14 a du livre
des procédures fiscales trouvera une
application plus que discrète
je ne comprends pas monsieur le ministre
comment on ne peut pas un moment ou à un
autre
avoir un compte je comprends qu'on
puisse pas contrôler toutes les
associations mais on pourrait quand même
essayer les labelliser on essaie on
pourrait essayer de trouver un
dispositif intelligent pour les
associations cultuelles qui profitent de
ces dispositions extrêmement large pour
proposer des déductions fiscales
alléchante
beaucoup d'associations passent entre
les mailles du filet je vous parlerai
parce que j'ai été menacé de mort et que
ça me semble une bonne idée de
recommencer deux d association qui
collecte des fonds pour l'armée
israélienne moi j'ai aucun problème pour
qu'on collecte des fonds sur l'armée
israélienne ce qui monte parce qu'il
m'ennuie c'est qu'une déduction fiscale
en tant que citoyen je vois pas pourquoi
je paierais pour l'armée israël
et puis de la même façon vous avez des
dîners caritatifs tout à fait
intéressants qui sont animés par des
salafistes connu et qui propose des
déductions fiscales là aussi tout ça
passe entre les mailles du filet je
crois qu'il faut que ça s'arrête
les dispositions que vous avez proposées
vont dans le bon sens il faut maintenant
aller plus avant
et puis monsieur le ministre de la même
façon moi je voudrais vous proposer
quelque chose parce que le conseil le
club nous a indiqué lors des auditions
qu'il n'y avait pas de lien entre des
financements étrangers des lieux de
culte et le financement du terrorisme
c'est quand même important
donc moi je voudrais vous proposer une
mesure qui n'est pas législatives mais
une mesure qui est un guide de bonne
conduite des ambassades étrangères parce
que lorsque vous demandez aux ambassades
étrangères en france la façon dont elle
finance les choses si on le demande on
trouvait avec mon collègue andré
reichardt nous avons ré interroger les
ambassades étrangères que nous avions
interrogé lors de notre apport de 2016
et qui nous ont répondu par exemple
l'arabie saoudite nous a donné une liste
exhaustive des financements en indiquant
que ces fonds avaient été transférés
directement du compte de l'ambassade aux
entreprises qui ont effectué des travaux
de construction sur rapport de
l'architecte du projet donc si on veut
suivre et financements étrangers c'est
assez facile on réunit les ambassades
étrangères d'alors dont on aura beau
demande d'appliquer un guide de bonne
conduite
celui par exemple de l'ambassade
d'arabie saoudite ou celui du koweït et
on règle une partie du fantasme d'une
france
abreuvés de pétrodollars j'admets
j'admets que la sphère de strasbourg en
ce moment arrive à point nommé
et quand on sait tous ce qu'est la
version ottomane de la gestion du culte
est un peu différente des autres mais en
attendant il ya quand même une réalité
qui est que ces financements étrangers
peuvent être contrôlés et moi j'approuve
fait les mesures qui vont qui vont dans
ce sens donc aujourd'hui sur les moyens
de financement du culte il faudra
renforcer évidemment les mesures
autonomes et moi je voulais vous dire
monsieur le ministre ma totale
opposition au projet d'un financement
qui passerait par un prélèvement sur le
hajj parce que partir sur un prélèvement
sur le hc se remettre dans un système
qui nous qui nous fait financé en partie
par l'arabie saoudite ce qui est le
contraire de ce qu'on voudrait faire en
revanche revenir sur la redevance halal
me semble une chose qui devrait être
mise
d'actualité et je reprendrai les
excellents propos du président larcher
dans cet excellent le guide qui explique
que l'état peut parfaitement aidé le
culte musulman pour un certain nombre de
mesures et voilà il convient donc
d'accompagner la communauté musulmane
avec exigence et d'abord à elle que
revient de s'organiser
voilà et donc il faudrait évidemment
l'accompagner et dans cet accompagnement
on pourrait imaginer que les services de
bercy aide à monter eux la tuyauterie da
d'une redevance halal qui permettrait
évidemment une indépendance du
financement du culte musulman en france
c'est évidemment cette redevance à
l'aller l'ensemble des moyens qui ont
fait exploser en vol le cfcm
il y a quelques jours je conçois que
l'ensemble ces dispositifs sont
extrêmement difficiles à mettre en place
mais je crois monsieur le ministre que
votre texte va vraiment dans le bon sens
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on propose les
choses ça fait trop longtemps qu ici une
partie de cet hémicycle les refusent
donc moi je soutiendrai toutes ces
mesures j'espère qu'au cours des débats
le texte ne déviera pas trop il ya des
dispositions sur lesquelles nous ne
pourrons pas voté mais sous réserve des
amendements et de la séance notre groupe
votera votre texte merci merci la parole
est maintenant à jacques bernard magner
pour l'europe socialistes écologistes et
républicains et pour quatre minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
république est une belle idée c'est un
bel idéal c'est celui d'une communauté
nationale une et indivisible dans
laquelle chacun à sa place
quels que soient son origine ses moyens
ses talents c'est pour c'est pourquoi
comme le disait montesquieu
vous l'avez rappelé le ministre d'autres
l'ont dit ici en moi il ne faut toucher
aux lois que d'une main tremblante et en
particulier celles qui concernent la
république
nous ne sommes pas sûrs que votre projet
de loi respecte ces précautions
élémentaires et nous craignons que le
texte qui sortira du sénat aggravera
encore ce sentiment
pourtant et plusieurs dispositions vont
dans la bonne direction
je veux parler de celles qui sont
relatives au respect de la laïcité si
essentiel pour nous mais malheureusement
trop régulièrement attaquée et de sel
confortant la neutralité du service
public
nous approuvons aussi l'idée de mieux
contrôler les financements étrangers des
associations cultuelles ainsi que le
fonctionnement des établissements hors
contrat mais d ambiguïté subsiste dans
votre projet de loi nous aurions aimé y
trouver des mesures pour renforcer la
mixité sociale à l'école car c'est là
que tout commence pour inculquer les
principes de la république
mais depuis quatre ans rien n'a été fait
dans cette direction alors que notre
école et sur de nombreux nombreux plans
porteuse de ségrégation et de
séparatisme votre texte reste hélas muet
sur ce sujet pour nous l'instruction
c'est d'abord dans l'école de la
république que cela se passe l'école
c'est le creuset de la rubrique où
commence l'apprentissage de la
citoyenneté enrichi par la mixité
sociale et le vivre ensemble
c'est à l'école que commence à se
construire la communauté nationale
mais c'est aussi grâce aux activités
associatives pendant les temps
périscolaires et dans les colonies de
vacances trop peu soutenu aujourd'hui
pour que les autres que les enfants de
ce pays apprennent à se connaître à se
respecter et à vivre ensemble et ce
n'est pas la création d'un service
national universel coup
et inutile qui résoudra la question de
la formation citoyenne des jeunes certes
par l'article 21 vous le souhaitiez
insérer les compte les contraintes sur
l'instruction en famille pour que les
enfants qui en auraient été éloignés de
cette école de la république la retrouve
l'école de la république
mais parallèlement vous encourager leur
inscription dans des établissements
privés hors contrat auquel votre texte
n'impose même pas le régime
d'autorisation même pas 7 ce régime que
vous vous demandez pour l'instruction en
famille c'est incohérent
non la droite sénatoriale ayant supprimé
cet article 21 en commission le groupe
socialiste va soutenir le gouvernement
aux seuls ministres
nous proposerons de rétablir cet article
21 et nous l'améliorons en contrepartie
nous attendons votre soutien pour enfin
légiférer sérieusement sur la création
des établissements d'enseignement
scolaire privé hors contrat en exigeant
l'autorisation préalable de l'état et du
maire avant toute ouverture et ceci par
simple cohérence et parallélisme des
formes avec votre article 21 originel
monsieur le ministre l'engagement
associatif sous toutes ses formes est
sans aucun doute l'un des piliers des
plus authentiques de la démocratie est
l'un des exercices les plus aboutis de
la citoyenneté par l'article 6 de votre
projet vous souhaitez mettre en place un
contrat d'engagement républicain qui
reste floue et dont l'utilité est tout à
fait discutable
il nous semble plus opportun de
reconnaître dans la loi la charte des
engagements réciproques qui depuis 2001
remplit déjà ce rôle contractuels
pourquoi voulez-vous encore corsetée un
monde associatif fragilisé est en
souffrance par des contraintes inadaptée
et contraire à l'esprit de la loi de 10
200 cadres article 8
il fait peser de nouvelles
responsabilités écrasantes et injuste
sur les épaules des dirigeants
associatifs et notamment les jeunes au
motif qu'un comportement inadapté d'un
membre pénaliserait l'association tout
entière ainsi que six dirigeants
les associations sont inquiètes et je
pense que la réglementation actuelle
permet d'intervenir
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
avons déposé des amendements
nous suivrons l'évolution de ceux ci
bras ce texte je remercie aussi la
parole est maintenant un monsieur
philippe bas pour les républicains et
pour six minutes monsieur le questeur
vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
chers collègues rapporteur chers
collègues
ce texte est une mosaïque on y traite de
l'héritage de la polygamie les mariages
forcés des imams détaché du droit
d'association des certificat de
virginité des réseaux sociaux de l'école
à la maison de la liberté du culte
tu es beaucoup d'autres questions je
félicite nos rapporteur d'en être venu à
bout et d'avoir même réussi à l'enrichir
beaucoup de mesures parmi celles que le
gouvernement propose mérite d'être
retenu leurs convergences que donner
sens à ce projet de loi sans qu'il soit
nécessaire de lui porter de lui prêter
une portée qui ne serait à voir
l'approché retenue n'est pas gage de
lisibilité
de nombreux régimes juridiques vont
ainsi être revu à l'aune de la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical en impactant
des pratiques profondément ancré dans
notre vie sociale qui ne sont nullement
blâmable et qui pour certaines d'entre
elles comme celle qui se rattache la
liberté d'association ont une valeur
civique qui les rend digne d'être
encouragée et non entravé ses textes
sacrés des formalités des obligations
des contrôles des restrictions il nous a
demandé de faire accepter aux français
le sacrifice d'une part de liberté au
nom du combat salutaire contre
l'islamisme radical
cela ne peut se faire de gaieté de coeur
même si la cause est juste
pour en arriver là le gouvernement
invoque un argument qui ressemble à une
excuse à cause du principe d'égalité
on ne peut faire une loi sur l'islam et
ses associations
il faudrait donc selon lui faire une loi
sur tous les cultes et toutes les
associations
cette approche me paraît contestable
nous n'avons pas plus besoin d'une loi
sur l'islam que d'une loi sur la
religion en général pour faire reculer
l'islamisme
ce combat est en effet un combat
politique et non religieux ce que nous
appelons police des cultes n'est pas une
police des croyances elles sont libres
c'est la police de la séparation du
politique et du religieux voulue par la
loi de 1905 dont les principes et des
règles restent d'actualité
mais toute assimilation entre chrétiens
d'hier et islamistes d'aujourd'hui
seraient historiquement fausse cher
dominique verrière ce que la république
doit viser ce sont les dérives
dogmatique d'un segment des voiliers de
l'islam qui contestent nos lois et notre
constitution
il s'agit de mener idéologique nous
avons voulu au sénat les tenir en échec
par la reconnaissance d'un nouveau
principe constitutionnel applicable à
l'ensemble des situations dans
lesquelles les salafistes avancent leurs
pions à l'école à l'hôpital dans les
centres sportifs et culturels et les
associations sur les lieux de travail
dans la vie en société vous ne l'avez
pas voulu vous avez eu tort
nous n'y avons pas renoncé s'agissant
des cultes
nous avons déjà des moyens d'action
important qu'il n'est pas interdit de
consolider fermeture des mosquées
expulsion d'imams étrangers condamnation
d incitation à la haine pénalisation de
toute mise en cause de la loi par un
ministre du culte tout ce qui va dans ce
sens peut aisément être approuvée mais
au cours des dernières années le
gouvernement ne semble pas avoir essayé
de mettre en oeuvre les sanctions de la
loi de 1905
qui permettent de punir l'intrusion
d'imams dans le champ politique
point de volonté gouvernementale point
de consigne aux préfets ni au procureur
la justice n'ait jamais saisi la loi
paraît oublié de ceux là même qui sont
en charge de l'appliquer et sans volonté
politique
à quoi servirait-il de la changer le
sénat a de longue date sonne l alarme
devant les progrès du salafisme qui
portent atteinte à l'unité de la nation
toute complaisance à son égard relève
d'une forme de complicité
ce projet de loi risque pourtant de
n'être qu'un tigre de papier car on
n'arrête pas les idéologies par des
barrières bureaucratiques ou budgétaire
les valeureux agents de nos préfectures
de nos directions des finances publiques
des poules rompt avec un soin méticuleux
les déclarations des cultes mais quoi de
plus facile que le respecter les formes
et les déclarations d'intention
qu'exigent les articles les plus naïfs
de ce texte il y aura plus de
contraintes pour ceux qui inscriront
leurs actions dans le cadre légal et
plus d'hypocrisie ou de clandestinité
pour les autres régir les lieux de culte
et leurs abords est une chose mais le
champ d'action des islamistes radicaux
ne s'arrête pas là il s'étend à la rue
aux associations aux réseaux sociaux et
au lieu d'habitation
pour tout dire monsieur le ministre je
ne crois pas à l'efficacité globale de
votre texte j'admets qu'il marque une
certaine prise de conscience de la
gravité des forces centrifuges qui
menacent notre nation il constitue à ce
titre un tournant dans la politique du
gouvernement
le président de la république paraît
enfin être passé de l'éloge du
multiculturalisme a une vision plus
exacte des menaces qui pèsent sur le
vivre ensemble
c'est un premier pas et malgré les
défauts de conception de ce projet de
loi nous pourrions vous laissez votre
chance
si vous acceptiez nos principaux
amendements
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à notre
deuxième questeur j'ai bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs il faut revenir à
l'essentiel
l'essentiel pour moi et mon propos
reprendra certains points puis
précédente orateurs l'essentiel ces
trois principes
premièrement la liberté de culte la
liberté de culte lé total en france la
laïcité garantit la liberté d'exercice
des cultes
deuxième principe l'état n'organise pas
les cultes
il n'a pas vocation à le faire et si
vous lisez ce projet de loi vous voyez
que dans bien des articles l'état d'une
certaine manière organise les cultes
troisième principe l'état fait respecter
la loi de la république
les cas n'organise pas les cultes mais
chaque fois que dans l'exercice d'un
culte la loi de la république est
bafouée alors l'état doit intervenir il
doit faire respecter la loi et il doit
appeler aux sanctions nécessaires si
dans un lieu de culte
il y à des propos racistes qui sont
tenues le racisme n'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit
eh bien l'état doit intervenir si l'on
respecte ces trois principes
je crois qu'on y voie clair et j'en
viens à la question que je posais déjà
tout à l'heure au regard de ces trois
principes
qu'est ce que ce texte apporte en quoi
il permet d'avancer d'agir vers l'objet
annoncé l'objet l'objectif annoncé
c'est lutter contre le salafisme radical
l'islamisme radical
l'islamiste doucoure le djihadisme
violent tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus mais en quoi
toutes ces mesures qui vont porter des
difficultés pour les associations et
pour les cultes
nous avons entendu tous les cultes et en
particulier ce que dit par exemple culte
protestant en quoi toutes ces mesures
vont avoir un quelconque effet par
rapport à ces jeunes et c'est moins
jeunes qui se radicalise qui se
détournent de la république qui se
détournent de la morale du respect de
l'être humain etc
c'est ça la question c'est pourquoi nous
avons posé la question préalable et nous
sommes persuadés que malheureusement ce
ne sont pas les voix qu'il faut choisir
de même êtes vous sûr monsieur le
ministre qu'en accroissant les
contraintes sur la loi de 1905
vous ferez que ceux qui sont régis par
la loi de 1901 choisissent désirent
s'inscrire dans le cadre de la loi de
1905 je n'en suis pas du tout sûr la
vraie question
elle est dans la vie dans les quartiers
vous l'avez dit moi j'avais fait un
rapport il ya très longtemps
refaire la ville pas seulement dans des
quartiers cesser tout ce qu'il faut
revoir refaire entièrement
parce qu'il ya des endroits en effet où
tout est à refaire ou la république et à
reconquérir
c'est vrai alors on peut passer du pain
on peut parler du passé d'hyères
d'avant-hier et d'encore avant moi qui
suis prêt mais c'est quand même là le
problème
de même l'école vous savez quatre jours
d'école
moi j'habite dans un quartier
périphérique dans une grande ville de
france
je vois les gamins à 10h30 ce qu'ils
sortent là qu'ils sont là l'emprise de
l'école elle s'est réduite par rapport à
l'emprise du
tout un tas d'influencés de toutes
sortes qui ne sont certes pas
républicaine il faut reconquérir et nous
appelons à cette reconquête
et comme madame la présidente mme appels
à conclure je dis que nous allons nous
battre monsieur min sur ces principes
clairs pour faire avancer véritablement
les choses vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président roger
karoutchi pour six minutes et pour le
robien républicain madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre c'est le président
de la commission mais d'un mime sur le
reporter pourquoi examiné aujourd'hui un
texte qu'on soit d'accord pas d'accord
d'ailleurs sur les finalités ou les
amendements parce qu'en réalité tout le
monde est conscient qu à force de coups
de canif à force de coups de poignard
les français se demandent s'il y a
encore une république dans ce pays
les français se demandent si est encore
une république respectée en tant que tel
et si cette république a encore du sens
par rapport à ce qu'elle a été
au niveau des fondateurs et la
république elle n'est pas de gauche
elle est pas de droite la république que
ce soit que ce soit dans les écrits à la
jeunesse de jaurès que ce soit à
l'échelle humaine de blum que ce soit
dans les mémoires d'espoir du général de
gaulle que ce soit dans les ouvrages
puisque on l'a beaucoup cité de georges
clemenceau par exemple dans les pensées
d'issoire la république elle est
toujours définie de la même manière la
république
elle est au dessus de tous les éléments
communautaire la république elle est au
dessus de toutes les croyances
la république elle est au dessus de
toutes les divisions
parce que la république en france et
nous ne sommes pas un pays anglo saxon
elle n'est pas fondée sur un agrégat de
communauté elle est fondée sur l'unité
de la nation
elle est fondée sur cette notion qui a
150 ans en france
la france est un creuset il faut
participer il faut définir un destin
commun il faut vouloir entrer dans la
nation et y participer pour être
français et pour défendre cette notion
de la république et la république
si on la conteste on peut la contester
on peut la critiquer on peut critiquer
les gouvernements mais ce qu on peut
critiquer le principe républicain parce
que critiquer le principe républicain
ces critiques en france le principe
national où allons nous où allons-nous
depuis quelques années et nous le savons
bien monsieur le ministre on voit bien
les coups de canif
on voit bien les acceptations du détail
des éléments particuliers ici on dit ah
dans cet établissement peut pas
enseigner la shoah coup de canif contre
la république
ici on dit ah oui mais la fois c'est au
dessus de la loi coup de canif contre la
république
ici on dit ah on doit pouvoir porter le
burqini dentelle piscine coup de canif
contre la république
ici on dit il faut des horaires séparés
homme-femme coup de canif contre la
république
le problème n'est pas de savoir s'il ya
un coup de canif
parce que quand y en a qu'un on se dit
problème passager qu'on va régler mais
l'accumulation le renouvellement la
force de ses coups de canif contre la
république remettent en cause l'adhésion
à la république remettent en cause la
force de la république
et si la république ne doit être ni de
gauche ni de droite
elle doit être respectée par tous parce
que monsieur le ministre
et ce texte va dans le bon sens
revue par la commission des lois alors
bien sûr il y aura des amendements jean
défendre et moi même j'ai bien compris
que la plupart ne serait pas adopté mais
peu importe
non mais merci monsieur loïc hervé de
remarquer que vous êtes là merci
monsieur loïc hervé je vous avais pas
interrompu jusque là mais merci de
parler mais la vérité c'est que est ce
qu'on peut avoir une république
incontesté dans ce pays
incontesté ça veut pas dire que tout le
monde doit avoir la même opinion doit
avoir la même religion doit avoir la
même organisation
ce pays a toujours connu et heureusement
des débats démocratiques longtemps entre
les communistes les gaullistes les
socialistes les libéraux les centristes
l'essentiel c'était le débat sur les
problèmes sociaux sur les problèmes
économiques sur les problèmes sociétaux
mais très peu sur les problèmes
d'adhésion à la république parce que
c'était une valeur universelle parce que
la notion de nation était partagée par
tous et que ça n'était pas ça le coeur
du débat le coeur du débat c'était un
combat écologiste pourquoi pas
socialistes communistes sur des égalités
des inégalités mais pas un combat par
rapport à ce qu'est la république pas un
combat par rapport à ce qu'est la nation
est aujourd'hui au delà du séparatisme
musulman islamiste
c'est très clair il ya un doute dans
l'opinion publique
participer à toutes les réunions avec
nos concitoyens
l'autorité de l'état il n'y croit plus
vraiment les engagements publics
il n'y croit plus vraiment la parole
publique il n'y croit plus vraiment ce
que peut faire le ce que peuvent faire
les élus le parlement voire l'état tout
entier il n'y croit plus vraiment
pourquoi parce que la remise en cause
constante régulière de la république
parce que la remise en cause régulières
de l'état pose problème
et lorsqu en parallèle et avec ça il ya
un doute sur ce qu'est l'avenir de la
nation
il ya un doute sur ce qu'est l'avenir de
la france il ya un doute sur ce qu'est
la notion même d'être français au 21e
siècle et bien vous avez un cocktail
explosif de critiques contre la
république de mise en doute de la
république et par conséquent d'un régime
qui peut devenir fragile oui monsieur le
ministre
et je pèse mes mots et je serai dans les
temps madame la présidente je pèse mes
mots
je considère qu'aujourd'hui
l'accumulation pas un élément précis
l'accumulation des coups de canifs remet
gravement en cause la stabilité de la
république et la durée la république et
que personne ne s'illusionne aucun
régime politique et éternelle et si nous
ne défendons pas la république la
république ne tiendra pas face aux coups
de boutoir de ses ennemis le
gouvernement le parlement quelles que
soient nos options politiques
ont-ils mission première défendre la
république
[Applaudissements]
là la parole est maintenant à monsieur
max brisson pour l'europe l'est
républicain pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
voilà un président tout monsieur
ministre mesdames c'est bien sûr les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues je
sentirai mon intervention sur les
articles concernant l'école
oui c'est un fait les tentations
séparatistes pénètre la république en
soccer le plus sacré que l'école de
moins en moins l'asile inviolable espéré
par jean v oui c'est un fait les
tentations séparatistes menacent
l'éducation de la jeunesse de france
bien entendu par l'existence d'enfants
hors radars de l'obligation destruction
qui ne sont ni ceux de l'école publique
ou privée ou ceux de l'instruction en
famille imparfaitement connues
identifiée déclaré recensés bien sûr par
les écoles de fait ces établissements
clandestins qui se développe sans même
avoir besoin d'utiliser le faux nez de
l'instruction en famille mais aussi par
les pressions qu'elles sont confrontées
enseignants et chefs d'établissement au
coeur même de l'école publique où
l'islamisme déstabilise professeurs et
enseignements dits scolaires et
périscolaires et même vivre ensemble
entre les garçons et les filles
ce projet de loi pour tout il des
réponses en matière d'éducation
malheureusement le faisceau républicain
rate la cible du séparatisme
il rate sa cible mais paradoxe il se
retourne contre l'un de ses piliers la
liberté d'enseignement
pourtant dès le 15 janvier 1850 victor
hugo déclaré à côté cette magnifique
instruction gratuite
je placerais sans hésiter la liberté
d'enseignement la liberté d'enseignement
pour les instituteurs privée la liberté
d'enseignement pour les corporations
religieuses la liberté d'enseignement
pleine entière absolue soumise aux lois
générales comme toutes les autres
libertés et je n'aurai pas besoin
de lui donner le pouvoir inquiet de
l'état pour surveillants parce que je
lui donnerai l'enseignement gratuit de
l'état pour votre poids votre projet de
loi monsieur le ministre en son article
21 symbolise bien ce pouvoir inquiet de
l'état
ainsi il n'hésite pas à jeter par dessus
bord la liberté d'enseignement en créant
un régime d'autorisations alors même que
vous avez été incapable au delà des cas
d'espèce d'étayer le moindre corollaire
entre instruction en famille est menacée
prat east alors que ni l'ampleur du
phénomène et encore moins les dérives ou
les infractions aux dispositifs non
juste ici le recul d'une liberté
fondamentale
avec ce texte la liberté de choix des
parents devient un motif de suspicion de
séparatisme
avant de tact les parents sont présumés
coupables de ne pas poursuivre l'intérêt
supérieur de leur propre enfant et la
puissance publique est jugé seul apte à
le définir
nous passons bien de contrôle a
posteriori que je ne discute pas un
contrôle sociétal a priori de
l'intention de la motivation même des
parents aussi
notre commission a eu la sagesse de
supprimer l'article 20 heures tout en
introduisant un certain nombre
d'éléments permettant de renforcer les
contrôles en cas de doute sérieux notre
commission ainsi rappelé avec force que
la liberté de choix des parents ne peut
être aligné à priori elle a rappelé
aussi avec force que les parents sont
les premiers et les ultimes éducateurs
de leurs enfants
elle a surtout rappelé que la
coexistence de propositions éducatives
variés et le signe d'une société
démocratique d'une société plurielle
d'une société respectueuse de la
diversité laquelle n'exclut pas la
concorde nationale
mes chers collègues à rebours du pouvoir
et y ait de l'état je souhaite
que l'examen de ce texte sont l'occasion
de changer de paradigme pour mieux
contrôler ce qui doit l'être sans faire
peser sur les familles qui ne faut pas
le choix de l'école publique une
insupportable présomption de culpabilité
si nous devons mieux armé l'école
publique et ses hussards noirs en
améliorant leur formation et en rompant
avec la culture du pas de vagues
si nous devons nous mobiliser pour que
l'instruction publique demeure
contrepoids et redeviennent porteuse de
promesses d'avenir pour les enfants de
ce pays
ce n'est pas en se reniant comme un état
inquiet que la république lutte aura
contre séparatisme
car si tu veux y avoir comme le
proclamer que manceau un conflit entre
la république et la liberté c'est bien
la république qui aurait tort c'est au
contraire en réaffirmant son attachement
viscéral à nos libertés fondamentales et
parmi elles la liberté d'enseignement
pleine entière absolue soumise aux lois
générales comme toutes les autres
libertés que la république puisera sa
pure de france
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
réagir à la discussion générale
merci madame la présidente je jouerai
remercier tous les orateurs nombreux qui
ont exprimé des positions extrêmement
complémentaires parfois contradictoires
j'ai même compris parfois des subtilités
parmi les expressions des groupes et
c'est bien naturel devant un débat et un
texte qui n'est pas celui sans doute des
frontières naturelles d opposition avec
ce que peut faire le gouvernement et
même dans les familles politiques
je devine bien et je le comprends des
différences d'appréciation et elles sont
à la fois le sel de notre débat
sénateurs karoutchi l'a évoqué et en
même temps elle crée par je crois une
envie collective de réussir au mieux
pour l'état pour la république et donc
pour l'intérêt général d'aboutir aux
meilleurs textes possibles
je me permet cependant de souligner
quelques points qui vont sans doute
revenir dans le débat mais évoqué en
introduction au long débat sur les peu
près 600 amendements que mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires vous avez
déposé le gouvernement au moins d'une
trentaine ainsi voulu respecter comme je
lé fais sur le texte précédent
évidemment le travail du parlement
ceux des points qui me paraissent
importants de sauver pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de difficultés entre nous sur la
compréhension la forme de ce que
souhaite faire le gouvernement et que
nous puissions assumer quand il y en a
des différences de fond d'abord je
voudrais évoquer la question très
importante
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises et par
tous les groupes politiques de la
maladie qui touche une religion dans
notre univers ne grandes religions dont
moi personnellement je pense et je crois
que c'est le cas de la quasi intégralité
des gens qui sont ici qu'aux plus
exprime la tribune qu'elle est
parfaitement compatible avec la
république et dans les pratiquants bien
évidemment non pas à montrer leur
attachement profond avec le sentiment
patriotique
je pense ici aux soldats de la première
et de la seconde guerre mondiale bien
sûr aux harkis et de tous ceux qui
engagés comme patriote dans la police
dans la gendarmerie dans l'armée au sein
du service public et de manière générale
en tant que français n'ont pas à rougir
de leur religion et bien évidemment
qu'on peut prier allah et être
parfaitement républicain je dis bien
volontiers que les territoires d'algérie
était même parfois français bien avant
d'autres territoires
ici encore représenter ce n'est pas une
statistique de le souligner est qu à la
tribune de l'assemblée nationale le
bachaga boualam lui-même en tenues
traditionnelles musulmanes se d'esprit
hier à l'hôtel de lassay tout en ayant
michel debré premier ministre et je
crois que cela ne choquait jadis
personnes cependant il est évident que
cette question n'est pas que national
cette question elle touche l'intégralité
du monde contemporain par sa profondeur
tout le monde connaît les difficultés
des écoles sunnites à pouvoir se mettre
d'accord sur une hernie ce thème que
nous appelons à un islam des familles ce
que nous connaissons sans doute le plus
parmi nos concitoyens mais qui peut être
accaparée par une minorité agissante qui
opère une au pea
ça s'appelle les islamistes et qui
aujourd'hui par exemple ont une au pea à
quasi 100 % sur internet et qui traverse
le monde musulman et la france comme de
grands pays sans doute qu'ils sont
regardés comme étant une lumière et qui
peut permettre effectivement à cet islam
de la raison de pouvoir ça gagne et
avicenne avait aures sur d'autres
penseurs plus difficile et en même temps
je veux aussi dire à quel point c'est un
phénomène mondial que nous subissons
comme tous les pays occidentaux mais en
premier lieu comme tous les pays
musulmans parce que les premières
victimes de l'islamisme ce sont les
musulmans les premières victimes des
islamistes ce sont les pays musulmans où
partout les islamistes ont été en
responsabilité
ça ne s'est terminée que par la pauvreté
la misère la guerre et les atrocités et
donc je veux vraiment dire que cette
situation n'est pas que nationale est
française et que bien évidemment le
projet de loi que dépose le gouvernement
n'a pas vocation à résoudre
l'intégralité de la difficulté qui
traverse une grande religion qui connaît
le crise très importante et chacun le
sait est que nous devons aider à notre
petit manière de réussir et de
convaincre le deuxième point évoqué et
peut-être les quelques erreurs
quelques incompréhensions que j'ai pu
entendre dans le débat si les orateurs
me le permettent à la fois peut-être
l'intervention de monsieur bah et du
président retailleau monsieur bah vous
avez évoqué peut-être en le regrettant
n'a pas évoqué le mot d'inventaire à la
prévert mais votre liste faisait penser
à cela
moi j'assume le fait qu'il faut tout un
village pour être vu qu'un enfant comme
dit le proverbe africain il faut
beaucoup de politiques publiques pour
enrayer un islamisme à séparatisme
diffus qui a pris des visages très
respectable dans beaucoup d'endroits de
la société et donc j'assume le patchwork
que vous évoquez si vous permettait
d'utiliser ce mot ici mais je veux dire
que lorsque vous dites qu'on évoque les
imams détachées vous avez tort
nulle part il est écrit nulle part il
est défini ce qu'est un ministre du
culte d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la loi de
le définir
nous ne savons pas ce qu'est un ministre
du culte et vous savez bien que même le
culte
ce n'est pas à vous que je vais
l'apprendre n'est pas défini dans le
droit français et qu' il est même refusé
d'imaginer qu'on le définisse parce que
ce n'est pas à nous autorité de l'état
considérait de ce qu'est un culte des
cultes on peut il y en a quelques-uns
qui sont cités c'est les plus connus
mais il y en a des milliers
et c'est culte la réplique n'a pas à les
reconnaître en tant que culte elle a
juste à voir si il rentre dans les
dispositions prévues par le législateur
puisque pour nous en tout cas pour
l'état français
la religion est une opinion les imams
détaché le président de la république a
pris une mesure extrêmement forte
bien avant ce texte il a été le premier
à dire que nous mettons fin en 2023
hauts fonctionnaires payés par des états
étrangers en l'occurrence des pays du
maghreb et la turquie pour pouvoir
enseigner la religion dans nos lieux de
culte en 2023 cela il fini c'est
extrêmement important comme mesure ça
veut dire que c'est la fin de l'islam
des consulats la fin de l'islam des
ambassades et l'idée première que nous
avons imposées aux protestants aux
catholiques ou juifs ton histoire de
l'état français d'avoir une affaire
religieuse qui ne concerne que les
français pour nous il n'ya pas de
musulmans d'origine algériens tunisiens
marocains qui devrait rendre
contes à je ne sais quel gouvernement
qui ne jure je ne sais quel diaspora
qu'elles soient financières auxquelles
soit électorale et c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet du courroux que je peux avoir
avec la mairie de strasbourg
nous ne devons pas des tendres dépendre
d'un état étranger pour gérer les
affaires religieuses françaises
si nous disions le contraire nous
accepterions que les musulmans par
définition ne pourrait pas être
pleinement français puisqu'il dépendrait
d'une autre autorité et c'est bien la
grande sécularisation de l'église de
france par exemple que d'être bien sûr
reconnaissante envers rome mais détache
et évidemment de la papauté
depuis philippe le bel qui montrent que
la religion en france est une affaire
française est saisie même détachée
monsieur le président bah c'est un texte
qui n'est pas législatif et prix bien
avant par le président de la république
ils vont créer une difficulté qui rend
absolument nécessaire ce texte c'est que
si nous ne voulons pas de financements
d'état
si nous voulons pas de financements
publics puisque nous ne revenons pas sur
les grands principes de 1905
certes pas consacré par le conseil
constitutionnel donnons subventionnement
et que nous voulons plus de financements
étrangers pour ne pas dépendre de
l'étranger alors il faut bien trouver
une source de financement national qui
est ni public ni étrangère d'où les
immeubles de rapport
et d'où les dispositions extrêmement
forte qui permette et jeudi au président
soeur qu'il se trompe
à mon avis lorsqu'il dit qu'il n'y a pas
d'intérêt de passer en 1905
bien au contraire qui permettent d'avoir
le denier du culte musulman ce que 92%
des associations cultuelles musulmanes
ne peuvent pas faire et en inégalité
total avec nos compatriotes juifs
protestants ou catholiques qui
permettent aux musulmans de ne pas payer
la taxe foncière déjà prévu dès 1905
pour les édifices cultuels et qui
permettent évidemment l'égalité de
traitement
en ce qui concerne la responsabilité le
juridique que permet 1905 ne permet pas
à 1901 en séparant profondément le
cultuel du culturel pour le président
vote à gauche j'ai du mal à avoir
compris la l'intervention mais sans
doute on en reparlera dans le débat
monsieur le président sur le
le conseil national des imams et
finalement l'idée de dire quelle drôle
d'idée que demander aux musulmans même
de s'organiser
le cfc pour l'instant j'entends bien au
cfcm est pour l'instant pour l'instant
on en parlera d'ailleurs vous aurez
l'occasion cette semaine sans doute de
voir que l'état prend des initiatives
extrêmement fortes pour permettre
l'organisation de des musulmans en
france
mais soyons monsieur le président
retailleau évidemment très clair dans
l'alternative
s'il ne s'est pas la représentation du
cfcm imaginée et créée par le président
sarkozy qui avait quelques désavantages
notamment le fait que c'était l'islam
considère qu'ils étaient représentés et
quelques avantages quand même c'était la
première fois qu'il y avait un semblant
d'organisation
après ce qu'a essayé de faire le
président chevènement qu'est-ce qui se
passe si nous le faisons nous mêmes
puisque je n'ai pas compris cela de
votre position mais si ce n'est pas le
cfcm pour l'instant l'instance
représentative des musulmans imparfaite
mais quand même et que nous ne faisons
pas cela nous-mêmes l'état puisque nous
empêcher de le faire en vertu des lois
de séparation des églises et de l'état
et que par ailleurs chacun constatera
qu'il n'ya pas de clergé dans l'islam
sunnite et que c'est bien une grande
difficulté qu'a le miso l'intérieur de
tout temps comme dirait les mauvais
étudiant de culture générale alors il
faudra bien que quelqu'un le fasse et ce
conseil national des imams qui prévoit
une sélection de responsables religieux
et est essentiel est pour l'instant bien
sûr qu'elle doit passer par le cfcm
monsieur le président retailleau la
grande difficulté qu'a le ministre de
l'intérieur et corrompt les prochains
miso l'intérieur c'est que lorsque je
discute avec le consistoire
je discute avec le président du
consistoire mais surtout le grand rabbin
qui peut engager le dogme de sa religion
et depuis au-moins napoléon et les douze
questions quand je discute avec le
président de la conférence des évêques
de france
je discute avec un religieux et des
religieuses qui évoquent et qu'ils
connaissent et qu'ils peuvent parler au
nom de la religion
lorsque je discute avec le président de
la fédération protestante je discute
avec un pasteur lorsque je discute comme
on discutait précédemment les murs
intérieurs et j'espère pas les prochains
avec les responsables des musulmans de
france je discute avec des présidents
d'association qui n'ont pas de dogme
religieux qu'ils portent et notre grande
difficulté c'est de permettre la
création
alors qu'elle n'est pas prévu dans ce
cynisme que nous connaissons une un
échange qui permet d'engager la voix des
musulmans de france en expliquant
l'interprétation qui évidemment la
grande règle qui permettra je le sais et
je sais que vous en êtes d'accord
la sécularisation on aura sans doute
l'occasion d'en reparler
j'oserais dire à monsieur brisson et à
l'ensemble des intervenants
même si monsieur mise et les questions
nationales et est parti sur la question
d'éducation
je regrette profondément la position de
la commission et du sénat pour une
partie d'entre elles et pas par
idéologie et par envie de refuser une
liberté à mes compatriotes mais inspiré
de mon expérience personnelle je peux
mais tenez quand même que nous puissions
si vous le permettez avoir un débat
autour des articles 21 et au tour sur le
bien fondé de ce que peut poser le
proposait le gouvernement
j'ai trop vu dans ma commune trop vu
dans ma commune la déscolarisation
notamment des petites filles en grand
nombre en quelques années de mer j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire qui pour me
permettre de penser que les choses sont
bien faites
quand on est maire quand on est maire et
vous l'avez été monsieur le maire quand
on est maire on n'a pas le fichier des
habitants de sa commune
certains peuvent le regretter dans le
côté droit de l'hémicycle
mais le fait est que nous n'avons pas le
fichier des habitants de sa commune
on a le fichier des électeurs par son
nom par son principe même ce sont des
français ou des citoyens communautaires
qui ont plus de 18 ans vous êtes dans
l'obligation légale d'inscrire des
enfants à l'école et vous n'avez pas la
possibilité d'aller dans les fichiers
sociaux qui nous permette de recouper ce
qui d'une part appartiennent au parc hlm
d'autre part qui touchent des
prestations sociales le troisième qui
touche un certain nombre d'indemnités
lorsque le maire fait son travail je
sais que comme 99 9%
il le fait avec l'aide des services
municipaux inscrire les enfants à
l'école
il ne sait pas ce qu'ils ne s'inscrivent
pas à l'école et j'ai découvert quand
j'étais maire jure que c'est arrivé à
chacune et à chacun d'entre vous dans
les territoires les plus compliqués des
petits fantômes de la république sur les
cinquante mille enfants 2019 monsieur le
sénateur qui était en instruction
famille 25000
c'est pour des raisons médicales 25000
ne l'était pas pour des raisons
médicales
je suis d'accord avec vous que l'immense
majorité sans doute des familles qui
éduquent leurs enfants le font
parfaitement encore là dessus avec les
valeurs de la république même si
personnellement je pense que c'est
jamais à mal qu'un enfants aillent à
l'école
monsieur karoutchi parler des piliers de
la république à coup sûr l'école fait
partie des pays et de la république
mais il ya eu il y a et je peux vous
témoigner que aujourd'hui encore il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui utilisent par les
parents la déscolarisation pour des
motifs de radicalisation ce serait être
aveugle que de ne pas le voir et à
marseille en une année on est passé de
650 enfants déscolarisés dans la ville
de marseille à 1250 monsieur le sénateur
en une année et je vais pas vous faire
la sociologie des quartiers qui sont les
plus concernées se sont pas ceux qui en
général ont des écoles privées sous
contrat ou des écoles publiques de
qualité à côté
malheureusement c'est dans la géographie
monsieur ravier tout à l'heure dans des
propos très excessifs
évidemment parler des quartiers qui
étaient sous emprise
j'en fait fermer monsieur le sénateur
avec le musée cachin nationale à
quasiment toutes les semaines des écoles
hors contrat à l'intérieur de ces écoles
hors contrats non déclarés
la quasi intégralité des enfants sont
inscrits instruction en famille la quasi
intégralité des petites filles qui
portent le hidjab à trois ans à terre ou
en cash la photo des animaux pour pas
qu'on voit leur tête avec on apprend des
trois ans l'arabe sont des versets du
coran sans fenêtre et on ne le fait et
je le dis ici devant la république et
c'est normal qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de dispositions du nouveau texte
on le fait qu'en vertu des mesures
soient sanitaire soit de rp alors qu'il
faille respecter la liberté
d'enseignement en famille le
gouvernement n'y a jamais voulu renoncer
mais le régime de déclaration je le dis
franchement comme je pense monsieur le
sénateur ne permettra pas justement la
teinte que nous voulons parce que la
déclaration elle se fait pour les gens
qui sont honnêtes quand vous faites
l'impôt à la source
legrand difficultés des gens qui
permettent de faire de pape vers leur
vie quasiment sans payer d'impôts c'est
basco déçoit régime déclaratif le
meilleur même pas avoir de contrôle
c'est quand ya pas de déclaration le
régime d'autorisation de liga
or permet le contrôle un pôle assurance
permet d'éviter que des gens échappent à
l'impôt notre droit français est un
droit qui est bâti sur une petite partie
de naïveté de la déclaration
nous devons tout en respectant la
liberté oui évidemment d'enseignement la
famille permettre une autorisation ou au
moins une inscription obligatoire
d'instruction en famille
c'est extrêmement important si nous
voulons lutter contre cette
radicalisation
bien évidemment bien évidemment nous
pouvons travailler et je crois que c'est
le sens du miz l'éducation nationale
avec le sénat et ses dispositions et sa
volonté mais nous devons rétablir une
forme d'article 21
parce que je crois profondément qu'une
partie de plus en plus importantes de
nos quartiers connaissent
malheureusement l'utilisation
d'instruction en famille pour des motifs
qui sont bien moins noble que ce que
vous avez évoqué la discussion générale
sur l'organisation des cultes et je
voudrais répondre ainsi à monsieur le
président sur vous dit qu'est ce que ça
peut changer vous n'êtes pas répondu aux
questions préalables qui m'avait pas
parue tout à fait être celle du
président kader mais je veux bien
effectivement répondre à votre
interrogation tout à fait légitime mais
de nombreuses choses de ce présent sur
le nombre choses d'abord nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter que 92% des lieux de
culte musulmans soient restés dans la
loi de 1901
c'est absolument impossible la volonté
gouvernementale aurait été de d'arrêter
et de rendre obligatoire sous cinq ans
le passage de 1900 1905 chacun
constatera que le conseil d'état dans un
avis extrêmement détaillées qui soutient
d'ailleurs très fortement le projet de
loi du gouvernement assez rare pour être
souligné dans un texte de cette nature a
dit que ce ne serait pas constitutionnel
mon travail de mise à l'intérieur ce ne
sont pas faire des rodomontades pour à
la fin avoir un texte qui est censuré
par le conseil constitutionnel
c'est de m'adapter à l'état de notre
droit et donc nous avons mis des
incitations extrêmement forte on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler jeudi serait
bien un petit tableau lors de la
commission du passage de 1901 en 1905
les financements monsieur présence
heures aujourd'hui nous ne connaissons
pas les financements étrangers sur notre
sol et il est normal je le dis ici que
ce soit aussi les associations de 1901
chacun sait que barack à city chacun
sait que human charity
chacun sait que un certain nombre
d'officines que l'on pourrait qualifier
d'islamistes sont financés par des états
ou des fédérations ou des intérêts
étrangers
sans être un lieu de culte
le milli gorus dont nous parlons depuis
quelques jours avec la ville de
strasbourg n'est pas une association
cultuelle
c'est une association qui est une
association tout court et donc il ne
faut pas être naïf et considéré que nous
devons connaître ces financements
étrangers
nous devons savoir qui finance quoi sur
notre sol et nous permettent de nous y
opposer
et cette disposition qui n'existe pas
sera d'un grand bien pour la république
et ce texte est évidemment extrêmement
nécessaire pour cela
merci à madame la sénatrice goulet de
l'avoir souligné et qui pour ce poste
pour l'instant été jusqu'à refuser
évidemment par les chambres
parlementaires j'espère que ce texte on
trouvera une issue plus positives de
même sur les lieux de culte nous ne
pouvons pas accepter de voir des lieux
de culte
quelle que soit leur religion être
vendues à l'étranger sûr que le
gouvernement n'est que mot à dire que
dire aux habitants d'angers lorsqu'on
apprend dans la presse que la mosquée
d'angers est vendu au gouvernement
marocain nous entendons bien au
gouvernement marocain c'est un
gouvernement ami de ce chacun sait que
les marocains sont les amis de la france
mais quand même si demain une telle au
lieu de culte serait vendu à la malaisie
seraient vendues au qatar seraient
vendues à l'arabie saoudite dans un de
vos départements vous tournerez la mise
à terre pour dire mais fait quelque
chose
la loi aujourd'hui est impossible pour
les intérieurs d'intervenir les
dispositions mises par l'assemblée
nationale lui permet de le faire
aujourd'hui vous pouvez être condamné
pour terrorisme
inscrit au fijais le fichier qu'évoquer
monsieur le garde des sceaux et dirigé
une association cultuelle
trouvez vous normal mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'on puisse
diriger une mosquée une église
si on a été condamné pour apologie du
terrorisme la loi prévoit évidemment
l'impossibilité de pouvoir diriger
quelle que soit la nature des fêtes qui
sont réglés relaté parce qu'on a été en
conclusion avec une entreprise
terroriste
un lieu de culte ça me paraît la moindre
des choses aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons
pas intervenir alors même que vous mmes
interpellé quasiment hebdomadairement et
c'est bien normal pour dire telle
personne connue des personnes condamnées
telle personne qu'à tels propos dirige
un lieu de culte près de chez moi
aujourd'hui la loi nous empêche
d'intervenir et 7 mois permet deux
aujourd'hui le mettre dans les formes
et puis je reviendrai pas sur les
immeubles de rapport et évidemment leur
importance ce président ottavio nous
avons effectivement pas choisi de faire
une loi ad hominem
dit aussi au président baki et
intermèdes hütthaler n'ont pas voulu
retirer la limite qui était celle de la
non reconnaissance des cultes pour un
fait de droit évident parce que c'est un
principe républicain ça a été rappelé
par plusieurs personnes notamment madame
de la gontrie
mais aussi pour une raisons
d'opportunité nous pensons sincèrement
que devant le moment grave que nous
connaissons les je rejoins vos propos
introductif nous ne nous avons un enjeu
qui est de pas faire basculer du côté
des islamistes
la très grande majorité des musulmans
qui bien évidemment se pose des
questions parce que ils se demandent
s'ils sont les bienvenus dans la
république si on respecte la vie de
leurs parents et leurs grands-parents si
leurs enfants pourront vivre de manière
libre dans le monde dans lequel nous
sommes parce que ils entendent ils
voient ils car ils vivent un certain
nombre de caricatures de leur foi et
nous devons les rassurer comme tous les
enfants de la république mais nous
devons aussi prendre en considération
que le combat idéologique des islamistes
c'est de récupérer la oumma de récupérer
la communauté alors que nous autres
réponses des raisons monsieur le
président retailleau c'est la communauté
nationale
il ya un combat pour cette communauté je
mets des guillemets et attention à la
mesure de trop attention à cette mesure
et c'est ça qui est très difficile et je
sais que vous le savez toutes et tous à
cette mesure qui ferait basculer du
mauvais côté
tous ceux qui parmi nos compatriotes de
façon tout à fait franche et de façon
tout à fait honnête se pose des
questions
devant ce qu'il voit de ce qu'ils
entendent et comment ils vivent la
république je suis d'accord qu'une
partie des interlocuteurs de gauche que
je sais que la droite doit penser la
même chose évidemment que l'urbanisme la
politique de peuplement l'immigration le
social l'éducation à sa place évidente
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
mais ce n'était pas un discours de
politique générale qu'on m'a demandé de
porter mais le projet de loi que je vous
évoque aujourd'hui si je devais résumer
en quelques mots mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je remercie ceux qui manifestement
apportent leur soutien au texte
je pense évidemment vous perdez pays je
pense aux radicaux
je pense aux centristes de manière
générale et je pense
le groupe qui est issu du modem et la
république en marche je comprends qu'il
ya des interrogations des alertes
disposions qui ne seront pas voté mais
je remercie par avance ses jeux
de ce soutien et il fait chaud au coeur
du gouvernement je comprends que la
gauche le parti communiste les
écologistes et les socialistes même s'il
trouve parfois soit le constat
intéressant soit des combats qu'ils
voteront ne voterons pas ce texte je le
regrette j'espère pouvoir vous
convaincre le plus possible évidemment
je respecte ses opinions et je comprends
des interventions c'était peut-être un
peu moins vrai à la fin notamment par le
sénateur karoutchi je n'ai pas tout à
fait compris quel était le vote et
sandoz attendez-vous les amendements du
groupe l'est républicain jeudi au groupe
l'est républicain en regrettant très
profondément les dispositions qu'on pût
exister à l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'il les députés du groupe les
républicains ont voté
83% des articles présentés par le
gouvernement pour la fin voté contre
je respecte ce vote évidemment et à
chaque fois ils m'ont livre sénart verra
comment on peut améliorer le texte de
nombreux abandons ont été pris par le
gouvernement de tous les groupes
d'ailleurs je voudrais le dire à
l'assemblée je redis au groupe l'est
républicain du sénat que cette ak
l'esprit de compromis entre le
gouvernement vient parce que c'est un
texte très important pour la république
mais si vous me permettez de citer un
auteur que n'ont pas cité
nos camarades communistes dans la rose
et le réséda devant les difficultés fou
qui fait le délicat et je vous conjure
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
temps est prêt c'est peut-être qu'il est
trop tardif mais mauguio tard mieux vaut
tard que jamais refusé une partie parce
qu'on voulait le tout n'a jamais fait
une politique d'un parti de gouvernement
[Musique]